ist denn das genau wie groß sind denn
die Löcher
das weiß man im Moment noch gar nicht
richtig an zu einer fitkau die Rede ist
häufig von 17 Milliarden Euro die im
nächsten Jahr fehlen könnten aber es
gibt doch ganz andere Zahlen die gehen
in den Bereiche von 22 Milliarden oder
sogar noch mehr so richtig fest scheint
das auch noch nicht zu stehen aber es
ist Handlungsbedarf da ist gar keine
Frage und deswegen wird heute in erster
Lesung über ein Gesetzentwurf zur
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Gesundheitsversorgung im Parlament
diskutiert wir nehmen ein paar Punkte
schon mal vorab und ich freue mich dass
heute morgen bei uns sind Heike Behrens
die gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und Sepp Müller
ist bei uns aus der Unionsfraktion da
ist der stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender und hat unter
anderem das Themengebiet Gesundheit
mitzuverantworten Frau Behrens was ist
der Grund für das aktuell erwartete
Defizit eigentlich ja ich glaube es sind
viele Gründe das eine ist natürlich dass
wir eine Pandemie nach wie vor zu
durchstehen haben die uns auch im
Gesundheitssystem enorm herausgefordert
hat und die auch mit dazu geführt hat
dass so mancher Reformen die eigentlich
naheliegen nicht angepackt worden also
beispielsweise im Bereich der
Krankenhäuser oder auch was eben der das
Arzneimittel neuordnungsgesetz anlang wo
wir eigentlich wissen was zu tun ist
aber das ist ein bisschen auf die lange
Bank geschoben worden am Ende der
letzten Legislaturperiode und jetzt muss
es angepackt werden aktuelle Probleme
nennt Frau Behrens Herr Müller auf der
anderen Seite auch strukturelle wie
beispielsweise die Lage der
Krankenhäuser sind Sie einverstanden mit
der Analyse im Großen und Ganzen gut wir
haben das eine Thema ist das sind die
Krankenhäuser wir haben das andere Thema
das ist das Thema ambulantisierung wir
wissen seit April von einem Gutachten
dass 2476 Leistungen ambulant
durchgeführt werden können ich bin das
beste Beispiel zwei Kreuzbandrisse das
kann man entweder ambulant durchführen
oder stationär im ambulanten Bereich
kostet es die Hälfte und da müssen wir
fitter werden und uns die
internationalen Partner anschauen das
können die besser und in die Richtung
muss es gehen auf der anderen Seite
soweit ich mich kann und soweit ich mich
so seitdem ich mich für Politik
interessiere ist immer wieder und immer
wieder die Finanzierung der
Krankenkassen ein großes Thema warum
gelingt es nicht das ganze mal
mittelfristig zu stabilisieren naja wir
befinden uns wirklich in der größten
Gesundheitskrise die wir in der
Nachkriegszeit hatten das muss man
einfach schon konzidieren aber wir haben
auf der anderen Seite wirklich auch ganz
grundlegende Probleme natürlich wenn die
Lasten der Gesundheitsversorgung
ausschließlich auf dem Rücken der
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
liegen dann heißt das natürlich auch
dass Schwankungen beispielsweise im
Wirtschaftsbereich wenn Kurzarbeit
gemacht wird wie wir das in den letzten
zwei Jahren ja mehrfach hatten dann
führt das zu Mindereinnahmen in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung während
die Ausgaben weiter
steigendemographiebedingt oder auch
aufgrund des medizinischen Fortschritts
und dann muss halt immer wieder neu eine
Balance hergestellt werden und dieses
Mal geht es darum wirklich
ein großes Defizit abzufedern die
Balance soll hergestellt werden
zumindest interessiert Pläne des
Gesundheitsministers wie sie ja
wahrscheinlich mittragen ich durch eine
ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen ich sage nur
ein paar Stichworte weil wir das im
Detail ja gar nicht ein richtig erörtern
konnten können es geht um die Anhebung
des Zusatzbeitrags es geht um eine extra
Abgabe der Pharmaindustrie es geht um
einen höheren Steuerzuschuss an den
Gesundheitsfonds der wiederum Geld
auszahlt an die Krankenkassen es geht um
ein Darlehen für den Bund an die
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung zum
Solidarbeiträge der Krankenkassen aus
deren Reserven und ein Erhöhung des
Apotheken Umschlags und Abschlags und
dann habe ich die Abschaffung der
neupatientenpauschale jetzt fast
vergessen aber dann doch nicht welchen
Punkt Herr Müller würden Sie sagen ja
das ist gut gut dass wir das so dass sie
im Koalition und das Gesundheitsminister
das so angeht ich habe am Anfang der
Legislaturperiode den Koalitionsvertrag
gelobt dass er unter anderem vorsieht
die Arbeitslosengeld 2 Bezieher und
Empfänger eins zu eins auszugleichen das
wären zehn Milliarden Euro da steht im
Koalitionsvertrag drin ich bin etwas
Gesetz dass diese Flickschusterei die
jetzt vorgelegt wird nicht dazu dienen
strukturell etwas zu tun insbesondere
dass der Koalitionsvertrag nicht
umgesetzt wird und darum kann ich zu den
Punkt nur sagen das ist nichts Halbes
und nichts Ganzes das wird uns nicht
helfen wir brauchen strukturellen
Zuschuss das ist das Thema
Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger deshalb
verstanden welche von den Punkten würden
sie trotzdem sagen okay gut dass man es
angeht weil es wird ja auf mehrere
Schultern verteilt also die Versicherten
sind dran die Apotheken sind werden zur
Kasse gebeten
Pharmaindustrie also wir hören von allen
Beteiligten in der Branche dass es nicht
ausreichend ist und diese Punkte sind
nicht ausreichend ich kann da keinen
Punkt rausgreifen den ich lobend erwähne
schade jetzt haben wir ich will da
vielleicht mal einen Haken weil den
Ausgleich für die zu geringen Beiträge
für die
alg2-bezieher wollte die SPD-Fraktion
auch in der letzten Legislaturperiode
sehr gern mit der cdu/csu auf dem Weg
bringen und sie wissen dass es ihre
Fraktion war die das abgelehnt hat noch
nicht gemacht hat von daher ist das ein
bisschen wohlfrei wenn man jetzt in der
Opposition mit einer sagt das was ihr
damals wolltet das würden wir jetzt
mitmachen also ich habe gerade überlegt
ob ich ihn nicht einen Beitrittsformular
für die SPD überreichen soll während ich
habe schon drauf gewartet dass Sie das
sagen aber ich glaube der Finanzminister
den ihr Haushaltsplan aufgelegt hat das
ist der jetzige Bundeskanzler und ich
habe da ganz andere Informationen das
nehme ich in der haushaltsausstellung
genau der Bundesfinanzminister Olaf
Scholz auf die Einhaltung des
Koalitionsvertrages in dem Punkt
verzichtet hat sie hören das wieder und
wieder von uns wir müssen die
Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger das sind
10 Milliarden Euro mit beteiligen das
ist eine volkswirtschaftliche Komponente
und ich kann es keiner Verkäuferin in
einem Supermarkt mit 1500 Euro brutto
erklären warum sie denjenigen
subventioniert der zu Hause sitzt das
funktioniert nicht das ist eine Aufgabe
des Staates und da stehen wir an der
Seite der geringenverdiener die jetzt
quersubventionieren Arbeitslosengeld 2
Empfänger das ist wunderbar wie sie das
Argumentieren und sie wissen dass das
die Position der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
ist aber
ja Herr Müller erstmal wünsche ich mir
dass sie sich durchsetzen in ihrer
eigenen Fraktion denn ich saß ja am
Montagabend mit Herrn sorge also ihrem
gesundheitspolitischen Sprecher auf dem
Podium bei der AOK und da wurde er auf
das Thema angesprochen und hat er gesagt
das ist eine Einzelmeinung in unserer
Fraktion also es ist mitnichten die
Position der cdu/csu und das finde ich
jetzt nicht ganz in Ordnung hier den
Eindruck zu erwecken als wären sie da
jetzt diejenigen die endlich zu den
Gerechten Beiträgen der alg2-bezieher
eintreten würden wir stehen jedenfalls
dafür und wir werden auch im weiteren
Verfahren und dafür einsetzen ich gebe
noch ein bisschen Input hier in dieses
muntere Gespräch in einem namensbeitrag
für die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung
haben sie Anfang September vorgeschlagen
Herr Müller die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze
anzuheben aber auch die
Versicherungspflichtgrenze wie viel
Unterstützung weil ich nehme den Punkt
mal
Behrens eben auf wie viel Unterstützung
haben Sie für diese Forderungen
innerhalb ihrer Fraktion und in ihrer
Partei ich habe Jubelstürme bekommen aus
allen Bereichen der Partei sie wissen
wir sind eine Volkspartei wir wissen
auch dass starke Schulter mehr leisten
müssen als schwacher tragen können und
vor dem Hintergrund gehen wir am
Dienstag gemeinsam in eine Klausur und
werden die Punkte die ich vorgeschlagen
habe unter anderem das von Ihnen
genannte aber vier weitere Punkte auch
miteinander besprechen und dann sehen
wir mal wie wir es am Ende ausgeht muss
ihren Jubelsturm glaube ich ein bisschen
korrigieren ich habe nämlich heute
morgen den bayerischen
Gesundheitsminister Holidaycheck in
Deutschlandfunk gehört der
im Grunde gar nicht eingegangen ist auf
diese beiden Punkten hat sie quasi zur
Kenntnis genommen aber dass er sie
unterstützt hätte kann man nur weiß Gott
nicht sagen eigentlich ist das aber doch
eine gute Idee dieser Vorschlag
abgesehen davon dass es wie nicht sicher
bin ob die Mehrheit in der
Unionsfraktion der tatsächlich steht
warum ist die SPD da nicht drauf
gekommen darauf sind wir allerdings
gekommen wir haben auch in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen genau für das
Thema uns eingesetzt weil ist völlig
richtig ist wie ist der Müller gerade
dargestellt hat starke Schultern müssen
mehr tragen als die schwächeren und
deshalb ist es überfällig dass man die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anhebt in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen war das noch
nicht möglich das mit der FDP zu einem
aber ich denke schon wenn es jetzt darum
geht wirklich dieses historisch hohe
strukturelle Defizit der Kassen
auszugleichen dann müssen wir dieses
Thema tatsächlich noch mal auf die
Tagesordnung bringen aber ich will schon
noch mal eins sagen Herr Möller weil das
hat ja immer auch was mit persönlicher
Glaubwürdigkeit zu tun und das sieht zum
Beispiel genau zum Jahresbeginn 2022 was
man ja ihren eigen ihrer eigenen
Homepage entnehmen kann in die private
Krankenversicherung gewechselt sind als
einer der eben ein hohes Einkommen hat
dann nehmen sie sich ja quasi aus der
Solidargemeinschaft heraus der
gesetzlich Versicherten und ich finde
das passt nicht so ganz damit zusammen
wenn Sie jetzt die Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze
dürft sie gerne irgendwie das eine hat
ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun das
Gute ist dass wir uns unterscheiden beim
Thema Bürgerversicherung ich glaube ihr
System ist ja dass wenn die Bürger dass
sie eine Bürgerversicherung wollen dass
alle einzahlen das wollen wir nicht wir
wollen bewusst dass beide Systeme
nebeneinander funktionieren wir wollen
nicht das amerikanische System und nur
privat wir wollen nicht nur das
britische System wo ab einem gewissen
Alter nur 30.000 Euro für die
medizinische Versorgung zur Verfügung
steht das wollen wir nicht darum möchten
wir das beide Systeme im System bleiben
und da brauche ich mich gar nicht
verstecken wie andere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auch wir haben eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe und da
gilt es jetzt gemeinsam zusammenzustehen
und da trägt die PKV die private
Krankenversicherung ihren Beitrag
unterträgt die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung auch ihren Beitrag
aber wenn sie lieferbarland sagt ein
richtigerweise sagen
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anheben und
Versicherungspflichtgrenze annehmen sind
sie trotzdem auf dem Weg dahin und das
was sie was Frau Behrens eben auch
gesagt hat das sind ja noch mal also was
starke Schultern das eine ist das Thema
Bürgerversicherung und das andere Thema
ist dass wir beide Systeme miteinander
erhalten wollen wir haben alles auf den
Tisch gelegt ich glaube auch Vorschläge
die man von der Fraktion nicht erwartet
hätte merkt man ja auch an den
Reaktionen die uns dann eher Zustimmung
geben und wir müssen in einem
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kompromiss
jetzt diese Mammutaufgabe GKV
Finanzierung und Krankenkassen
Finanzierung an dem Weg dem wir reichen
die Hand auch der Ampelkoalition und
möchten diesen Weg gemeinsam beschreiten
und freuen uns auf die Einladung um hier
eine Lösung herbeizuführen wir werden
das beobachten weil du im neuen Jahr
auch die Debatte dazu stattfindet ich
habe nur einen Punkt noch wo ich ihre
Meinung gerne noch zu wüsste es gibt
auch Vorschläge aus den Krankenkassen
und da ist mir aufgefallen zum einen
wird vorgeschlagen eine Zuckersteuer
einzuführen weil ja gerade durch Zucker
und falsche Ernährung auch das Kranken
Gesundheitssystem belastet wird und auf
der anderen Seite gab es einen Vorschlag
die Krankenkassen zu beteiligen an
Einnahmen aus Tabak und Alkoholsteuer
wie stehen Sie dazu definitiv
müssen wir in unserem Gesundheitssystem
den die Aspekte Gesundheitsvorsorge und
Prävention Stärken weil wir ja es muss
stärker unser Anliegen sein das krank
werden zu vermeiden und von daher sind
diese Vorschläge natürlich gehen in eine
sinnvolle Richtung wie aber die
Geldströme am Ende laufen das muss
politisch entschieden werden darüber
müssen wir diskutieren aber alles was
der Gesundheitsvorsorge und Prävention
dient ist auf jeden Fall wichtig und da
müssen wir noch einen Schritt
weiterkommen das ist ihre Perspektive
Herr Müller dabei ja gut zusätzliche
Steuern zu erheben um in das bereits
großes System einzuszahlen da mache ich
mal ein großes Fragezeichen dahinter wir
haben strukturelle Probleme sie haben
einiges angesprochen ob da zusätzliche
Geldeinnahmen helfen diese strukturellen
Probleme die da sind zu lösen groß
Fragezeichen
die strukturellen Probleme lösen und
trotzdem dafür sorgen dass die Kassen
genug Geld zur Verfügung haben für das
was sie eigentlich leisten sollen Frau
während vielen Dank dass Sie heute
morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch Ihnen
Herr Müller vielen Dank sie dürfen sie
müssen sogar rein in den Plenarsaal ich
wende mit unseren Publikum kurz zu wir
schauen ein bisschen auf das was heute
Vormittag hier im Deutschen Bundestag
passiert und da wird es zunächst eine
Gedenkminute geben ein Gedenken dass
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars aussprechen
wird an den
SPD-Abgeordneten Rainer Keller der
gestern im Alter von 56 Jahren
überraschend unerwartet gestorben ist
das wurde schon gestern eine
gedenkminute-veranstaltet hier im Plenum
die
Abgeordneten haben sich davon ihren
Plätzen erhoben und wie gesagt Bärbel
Bass wird auch die heutige Sitzung damit
beginnen und dann geht es im Anschluss
weiter während wir jetzt doch schon mal
in den Plenarsaal reingucken könnten
dann geht es im Anschluss weiter mit der
ersten Lesung eben dieses Gesetzentwurfs
zur Finanzierung der
Gesundheitsversorgung es gibt auch noch
eine Reihe von Anträgen dazu aber darauf
werden wir dann später eingehen
Bundestagspräsidentin ist so gut wie da
und damit hinein in den Plenarsaal
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen guten Morgen die Sitzung
ist eröffnet bitte nehmen Sie Platz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gestern ist unser Kollege Rainer Keller
im Alter von nur 56 Jahren gestorben
wir sind tief bestürzt über seinen
plötzlichen Tod
mit Rainer Keller verlieren wir einen
überaus engagierten Kollegen vor einem
Jahr wurde er direkt in den Bundestag
gewählt
Rainer Keller gehörte drei Ausschüssen
an und war unter anderem auch
stellvertretendes Mitglied im
Untersuchungsausschuss Afghanistan
wir haben Ihnen als ein Abgeordneten
erlebt der seine Lebenserfahrung aktiv
in Debatten einbrachte
es stand für seine Überzeugung ein und
pflegte das offene und klare Wort
die Menschen sollten wissen wofür es
steht das war sein Credo
der Krankenpfleger und Notfallsanitäter
war immer da wenn er gebraucht wurde er
engagierte sich mit viel Herzblut für
seinen Wahlkreis Wesel 1 aber auch für
Menschenrechte
Demokratie und Pluralismus weltweit
seine aufrichtige Art und sein Einsatz
für die Menschen werden uns fehlen wir
trauen mit seiner Familie und seinen
Angehörigen
sie haben sich von den Plätzen erhoben
ich bitte Sie jetzt noch eine Minute im
Gedenken für den Verstorbenen
vielen Dank
ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
28a bis 28g
Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur
finanziellen Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung zur
Krankenhausfinanzierung sowie zur
Arzneimittelsicherheit und Versorgung
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die Bundesregierung der
Bundesminister für Gesundheit Professor
Dr Karl Lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Lieben und
Kollegen und Kollegen lassen Sie mich
auch bitte beginnen indem ich den
Angehörigen von Rainer ganz herzlich
mein Beileid Ausdrücke er war auch für
unser Haus immer ein wichtiger
Ansprechpartner ein wichtiger Ratgeber
wir werden den vermissen
die gesetzliche Regelung die wir heute
besprechen in der Krankenversicherung
ist der Tatsache geschuldet dass in der
letzten Legislaturperiode den Aufbau
eines großen Defizits in der
Krankenversicherung gegeben hat in
dieser Größenordnung kann man sagen
historisch entstanden durch den
demografischen Wandel in unserer
Gesellschaft die bessere Technologie
aber auch der Tatsache dass hier
Strukturreformen ausgeblieben sind das
ist keine Kritik sondern dass der
Tatsache geschuldet dass andere
Schwerpunkte im Vordergrund gestanden
sind die pandemiebekämpfung somit ist es
ein geerbtes Defizit aber das werden wir
gemeinsam beseitigen wir müssen es
beseitigen in dem Geist keine
Schuldzuweisungen aber gemeinsam daran
gehen und dabei habe ich mich oder dabei
haben wir uns im Haus auch von drei
Grundprinzipien leiten lassen das
wichtigste Grundprinzip bin ich im
Vordergrund stellen und daran werden wir
nicht rütteln werden wenn der gesamten
Legislaturperiode nicht rütteln wir
wollen
Land Leistungskürzungen
leistungskurzungen in einer Zeit wo die
Menschen bedroht sind durch Krieg
Inflation steigende Energiepreise
möglicherweise Rezession das ist eine
Situation wo Kürzungen der
Gesundheitsversorgung nicht vermittelbar
sind mir wird das immer wieder
vorgeschlagen ich lehne dies ab wir
müssen in einer solchen Zeit
zusammenhalten es kann nicht sein dass
die Menschen in solchen Phase
gesundheitskostungen
Einschränkungen im Leistungskatalog
hinlegen das werden wir nicht mitmachen
das haben wir da durch diese
reformbetrag ich bitte dafür auch um die
Unterstützung im ganzen Haus ganz im
Haus diese Sicherheit müssen wir den
Menschen bieten auch in der in dem in
der Gefahr im Wandel auf die
Gesundheitsversorgung kann man sich
verlassen zum zweiten es ist richtig
dass wir zuerst ein Effizienzreserven
herangehen bevor wir Beitragssätze und
in diesem System sind viele
Effizienzreserven einige der wichtigen
Effizienzreserven gehen wir ja nicht
wird ein paar Beispiele nachher bringen
was durch Effizienz Reserven nicht
gewinnbar ist das muss dann fair
verteilt werden die lassen die dann
übrig bleiben über Steuermittel dann
aber auch über moderate
Beitragssatzerhöhung aber auch unter
Beteiligung der Arbeitgeber sage ich
ausdrücklich denn Zusatzbeiträge sind ja
paritätisch bezahlt es kann nicht sein
dass alles Beiträge der Arbeitnehmer und
der Steuerzahler sind die Arbeitgeber
beteiligen sich nicht daher eine faire
Verteilung auf alle Schultern ist
richtig und die stärksten schultern
müssen das Maße tragen
wieso sind hier noch Effizienzreserven
vorhanden also wie kann es überhaupt
sein ich bringe ein Beispiel die
Krankenkassen haben durch die
Wettbewerbsverzerrungen die es früher
gegeben hat auch ganz unterschiedliche
Rücklagen es gibt also Krankenkassen die
haben hohe klagen und es gibt
Krankenkassen die haben sehr niedrige
Rücklagen das verzehrt natürlich den
Wettbewerb und somit müssen diese
Rücklagen zuerst einmal der Versorgung
zugeführt werden wenn wir das nicht tun
dann passiert das was wir jetzt auch als
es angekündigt wurde zu sehen war die
Krankenkassen die viele Rücklagen haben
die stocken zum Beispiel ihre eigenen
vorstandsalters Rückstellungen massiv
auf es sind tatsächlich auch
Krankenkassen ich möchte hier wirklich
nicht in eine polemische
vergleichsdeparteien steigen aber es
sind Krankenkassen wo die Vorstände
deutlich mehr verdienen als der
Bundeskanzler auch darüber muss
nachgedacht werden die
asiatusrückstellung sind so hoch dass
hier Vergütungen bezahlt werden können
die unvergleichbar sind was der normale
körperversicherte verdient da diese
Rückstellungen zurückzuführen halte ich
für richtig insbesondere in einer Zeit
wo wir sonst an die Beitragssätze heran
müssen oder die Versicherten belasten
müssen
ich will ein paar Beispiele kurz dafür
bringen wir so wie Effizienzreserven
gehoben haben wo die Versorgung nicht
schlecht wird ich bin ein Beispiel was
wir zum hier zum Beispiel machen wir
bereinigen im Krankenhaus das
pflegebudget war die Pflege wird jetzt
was gut ist über die Kostendeckung
direkt erstattet es gibt aber beim
Pflege Budget noch eine rechtskonstante
in der fahrpauschale somit wird dort die
Pflege doppelt abgerechnet das haben wir
beseitigt das ist einfach fair und
richtig da wird die Versorgung nicht
schlechter oder wir haben beispielsweise
im Bereich der Arzneimitteltherapie
dafür gesorgt dass also sehr hohe Preise
mit den neuen Medikamenten in den Markt
kommen das kann in dieser Form sowieso
nur noch in Deutschland passieren wir
sind daher der innovationsfreundlichste
Pharmamarkt in ganz Europa die
Pharmafirmen wollen vieles verändern
aber sie wollen kein anderes
Vergütungssystem aus Europa nur unseres
aber wir haben dann tatsächlich die Zeit
wo diese hohen Preise unverändert gelten
hier haben wir auf sechs Monate ge das
ist einfach fair es kann nicht sein dass
ein Preis der belegterweise zu hoch ist
dann noch sechs Monate in der überhöhten
Form weiter genommen wird das ist
einfach unfair das ist Effizienz Reserve
das ist im lobbydruck der vergangenen
Jahre geschuldet das haben wir beseitigt
in einer solchen Zeit müssen wir auch
gemeinsam bei allem Verständnis für die
Lobbygruppen die bei uns jeden Tag
Vorsprechen müssen wir für die
Versicherten müssen wir für die
Verbraucher die Steuerzahler die
Beitragszahler stehen und das haben wir
in dieser Reform gewagt und werden uns
auch weiter tun bei unberechtigten
Angriffen werden wir dem lobbydruck
standhalten das sind wir den
Versicherten den Menschen in Deutschland
schuldig sonst steigt der Beitragssatz
unnötigerweise das ist nicht hinzunehmen
es war nicht alles durch also
Effizienzreserven gewinnbar ich könnte
weitere Beispiele bringen zum Schluss
ist dann doch noch etwas übrig geblieben
was wir fair verteilen müssen da
belasten wir den Steuerzahler der
Zuschuss steigt um 2 Milliarden Euro wir
arbeiten kurzfristig mit einem Darlehen
von einer Milliarde Euro um die
Schuldenbremse nicht zu überschreiten
und wir erhöhen den Beitragssatz um 0,3
auch das ist nicht unfair weil im
Gegensatz zu Steuermitteln bezahlt ihr
der Arbeitgeber die Hälfte mit also die
Arbeitgeber werden mit ins Boot genommen
somit diese gleich die ja auch die
gesetzlich krankenversichert auch die
Gesetze aber es ist nur
0,15 Beitragssatzpunkte mehr ist es
nicht der allergrößte Teil der
allergrößte Teil was auf den Punkt zu
bringen der allergrößte Teil 90 Prozent
dieser Reform werden nicht durch die
Erhöhungen des Beitragssatzes 90% bitte
nicht durch die Erhöhung des
Beitragssatzes auf gkv-seite auf der
Arbeitnehmerseite bezahlt 90 Prozent
diese zehn Prozent haben wir zugemutet
das halte ich aber auch für vertretbar
es sind zehn Prozent 90 Prozent werden
über andere Quellen also werden die
generiert ich komme zum Schluss wir
werden hier folgendes also feststellen
nach der Reform ist vor der Reform weil
wir brauchen tatsächlich langfristig
eine wesentliche Strukturreform der Art
und Weise wie die Krankenversicherung
bezahlen ich habe jetzt hier einmal
Effizienz Reserven mobilisiert die in
keinem Fall zu einer Verschlechterung
der Versorgung für den km/harzigen Fall
aber langfristig müssen wir natürlich
die Reform bringen und daran arbeiten
wir auch wir müssen tatsächlich die
Beiträge für Arbeitslosengeld 2
Empfänger die müssen wir fairer
gestalten erhöhen wir müssen den
Bundeszuschuss den es gibt dynamisiert
kann nicht sein dass die Menschen immer
älter werden wird nicht dynamisiert und
somit wir aber noch arbeiten auch an
dieser Reform aber ich bitte einfach um
Verständnis dass wir die
Effizienzreserven erst einmal heben
müssen dann gehen wir an diese Reform
diese Brücke werden wir überschreiten
wenn wir Sie erreichen und wir werden
auch kurzfristig das möchte ich auch
noch sagen für die erheblichen
Energiekosten die Krankenhause haben die
inflationskosten für die Mehrbelastungen
in der Pflege bei den Eigenanteilen auch
dafür werde ich von dieser Stelle in
Zukunft in Kürze Vorschläge Vorbringen
aber wir müssen das getrennt sind
Effizienzreserven die Reform von heute
eine Finanzreform die Reform von morgen
und dann die Beseitigung der Belastungen
Eigenanteile in der Pflege aber auch in
den also in den Krankenhäusern das ist
die Reform ebenfalls die in Kürze
vorgestellt werden so dass wir das
gemeinsam schaffen bitte unterstützen
Sie diese Reformen
versparen Sie uns mit Polemik lassen Sie
uns gemeinsam über Lösungen nachdenken
vielen dank Ihnen für die Aufmerksamkeit
mit mit einem Appell Ende der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nachdem er
erläutert hat seine Vorstellungen wie
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
finanziell stabilisiert werden kann
erste Beratung erste Lesung dieses
Gesetzentwurfs und jetzt kommt aus den
Ländern ein Vertreter nämlich der
bayerische Minister für Gesundheit und
Pflege Klaus hollitschek frau
Präsidentin hohes Haus lieber Kollege
Lauterbach meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren erstmal will ich feststellen dass
es gut ist dass wir uns heute mal über
die essentiellen Themen unterhalten in
Gesundheit und Pflege mal nicht über
Corona auch noch ein wichtiges Thema
aber jetzt geht es mal an die Substanz
die Themen die die Menschen bewegen wie
finanzieren wir das System wir könnten
heute auch über Pflegeversicherung
sprechen auch ein Desaster wir könnten
über Krankenhausfinanzierung sprechen
auch noch nicht weiter über
sektorenübergreifende Versorgung auch
noch nichts gehört alles Themen die
wichtige und wichtig sind stattdessen
legen Sie heute ein Gesetz vor unter dem
Titel
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz wissen Sie
was das ist es ist ein
versorgungs-destabilisierungsgesetz und
eigentlich hätte der Finanzminister des
einbringen müssen und nicht sicher
Kollege Lauterbach weil die Wahrheit ist
doch das Gesundheitspolitik inzwischen
entweder vom Justizminister oder vom
Finanzminister gemacht das ist keine
Probleme sondern ist meine Erfahrungen
auch aus den Diskussionen in der
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz wo zum
Schluss immer der Satz kommt muss man
schauen was der Herr Lindner dazu sagt
das ist ein eine Kapitulation wenn
Gesundheitspolitik nicht mehr von den
Gesundheitspolitikern gemacht wird
und natürlich wissen wir dass die GKV
die Basis des Gesundheitssystems ist und
wir wissen dass wir im Moment in
schwierigen Zeiten sind Inflation
Energiekosten und wenn die Beiträge
steigen ist das kein gutes Signal für
die Menschen in unserem Land vor diesen
schweren Winter der uns vorsteht sie
steuern auf einen Kassen Crash zu auf
einem Blackout der Versorgung wenn sie
so weitermachen und dann nützt es nichts
wenn Sie ankündigen wir werden dann was
vorlegen jetzt müssen sie vorlegen jetzt
müssen sie es machen
und es steht ja auch in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag drin dass die Beiträge
Arbeitslosengeld zwei Versicherung
auskömmlich sein sollen wir reden davon
10 Milliarden Euro also es muss hier was
passieren und es darf nicht bei einer
Ankündigung bleiben dass man das
irgendwann tut und irgendwann macht die
zwei Milliarden Bundeszuschuss sind da
einfach viel zu wenig auch die
Dynamisierung des Zuschusses ist
notwendig und richtig und sie sehen doch
die Krankenkassen werden abgeschöpft das
ist kontraproduktiv erst hören dann
stören das ist ein wichtiger Satz der
gilt überall
im bayerischen Landesparlament aber auch
im Deutschen Bundestag den ich selber
mal angehörte von 98 bis 2002 also wir
wissen dass das Abschaffen der
krankenkassenreserven der falsche Weg
ist meine Damen und Herren wenn ich
heute lese das sogar ihr Projekt des
gesundheitskiosk jetzt von den Kassen
nicht mehr finanziert wird weil sie
sehen dass die Politik diese machen den
falschen Weg beschreitert dann sollte
Ihnen das schon zu denken geben lieber
Kollege
und wir wissen noch dass die
Steigerungen weitergehen wenn ich jetzt
sehe durch die richtige und wichtige
Aufnahme der ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
aber in das Leistungssystem die
Überführung wird nochmal eine Milliarde
an Defizit entstehen das kommt noch oben
drauf auf dieses ganze Thema und
deswegen glaube ich stehen wir schon vor
ganz schwierigen Zeiten natürlich wollen
wir zusammenhalten Herr Kollege
Lauterbach das ist unbestritten Länder
und Bund gemeinsam das machen wir in der
GMK auch glaube ich immer deutlich aber
sie setzen nun mal die falschen
Schwerpunkte die Abschaffung der des
Budgets für die neupatientenregelung
wissen Sie was das ist ist eine
Leistungskürzung Herr Kollege Lauterbach
das können sie schön reden wie sie
wollen
wenn ich alleine die Wartezeiten sehe in
der
Psychotherapeuten Frage in der
versorgungsfreiheit ist es eine
Leistungskürzung reden sie doch nicht
drum rum machen sie sich ehrlich in
diesen Fragen das nützt doch nichts oder
bei den Zahnärzten die
Parodontitis-Therapie ja irre das haben
wir jetzt gerade erst aufgenommen das
geht ja an die Grundversorgung an die
Grundfesten mithin jetzt schaffen wir es
wieder ab
und mit Verlaub des pflegebudget ich
halte das wirklich für einen Irrsinn wir
brauchen in der Pflege jetzt große Würfe
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen wirklich eine
Revolution in der Pflege ich nehme das
Wort nicht oft in den Mund aber es ist
so wir müssen mutig sein und nach vorne
gehen und sie kürzen jetzt das
pflege-budget sie nehmen Leute raus wie
Hebammen zum Beispiel und andere die
nicht mehr refinanziert werden und
schaffen noch mal eine Verschärfung in
diesen wichtigen Bereich statt dass wir
alles tun damit die Pflege spürt wir
stehen hinter ihr Schaffen sie hier
kontraproduktiv genau den falschen
und ich will schon noch was sagen auch
zum Thema Arzneimittel die
pharmabbranche und alle wollen einem
Beitrag leisten darum geht es gar nicht
und die muss nach einem Beitrag leisten
aber wie man das macht ohne den Dialog
Herr Kollege Ullmann mit den Unternehmen
zu führen ohne einen Farmer Dialog
anzustoßen wir werden in den
innovations- und Forschungsstandort
Deutschland hier kaputt machen wir
feiern ihn für die Impfstoffe für
paxlovit und für Medikamente und wir
machen ihn hier kaputt weil wissen sie
Wirtschaft hat das mit Vertrauen zu tun
und wenn Unternehmer nicht mehr in die
Rahmenbedingungen vertrauen können dann
werden sie den Standort verlagern und
das ist der Fehler es geht nicht um
einen gerechten Beitrag zu bringen es
geht um die Frage wie man das macht wie
man den Dialog führt und wie man mit
diesen Unternehmen umgeht die Innovation
und Forschung für die Menschen machen es
geht um beste Medizin für die Menschen
und das muss uns bewegen und muss uns
auch gemeinsam nach vorne kommen
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der FDP-Fraktion von Herrn
Ullmann
zulassen wie Sie wissen komme ich aus
Unterfranken und sie kritisieren jetzt
in ausgiebiger Rede die
Fehlentscheidungen der vorhergehenden
Gesundheitsminister die auch
unionsgeführt sind meine Frage konkrete
an sie für uns in Bayern ist die
bayerische Staatsregierung dazu jetzt
bereit auch die Krankenhausfinanzierung
nicht nachzukommen und die Finanzierung
der Krankenhäuser in Bayern
voranzutreiben
ich bin in den außerordentlich dankbar
für diese Frage Bayern investiert 643
Millionen in der dualen
Krankenhausfinanzierung seit 1972
fließen 25 Milliarden in bayerische
Krankenhäusern davon 60% in den
ländlichen Raum jetzt müssen die
Hausaufgaben gemacht werden bei dem
Thema die a cheese das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe das ist die Aufgabe die hier
passieren muss und da warten wir dass
die Dinge endlich gemacht werden
ich will ihnen nochmal sagen ich glaube
dass die Situation zu explodierenden
Beiträgen führt bei den Kassen
vielleicht sogar zu Schließungen zu
einer weiteren Konzentration Dinge die
nicht gut sind und die schwierig sind
deswegen müssen wir da dagegen steuern
ich würde mir auch wünschen Herr Kollege
Lauterbach dass wir jetzt ein Moratorium
für Bürokratieabbau auf den Weg bringen
auch ein wichtiges und zentrales Thema
wir müssen es tun
ich werde das wieder schaffen wenn wir
es jetzt nicht tun und nicht nur darüber
reden und zum Schluss bitte kündigen Sie
dieses Programm jetzt nicht mehr an
machen sie es auch jetzt Energiekosten
Pflege Reha Krankenhäuser wir kriegen
einen kalten Strukturwandel im
ländlichen Raum die Krankenhäuser werden
es nicht schaffen 2,8 Milliarden
sachkostensteigerung dieses Jahr 1,7
Millionen Energiekosten das ist nicht
mehr tragbar und wir dürfen nicht mehr
warten jeder Tag ist verloren
und die Pflege ist genauso da wird auch
das Wohngeld nicht reichen das wird
nicht reichen in der Substanz und auch
Reha-Einrichtungen wird zerstören jetzt
Dinge die wir nachher wieder brauchen
denken Sie an long und Bosco wird ihnen
brauche ich das nicht sagen weil sie um
die Bedeutung wissen wenn Reha nicht
mehr funktioniert dann wird auch diese
Struktur nicht mehr da sein sind Sie
mutig setzen Sie sich in der Koalition
durch machen sie Gesundheitspolitik für
die Menschen in unserem Land die haben
es verdient und nach der Pandemie erst
recht
Bayerns Gesundheitsminister Klaus
holletschek in einer Debatte in der es
über das Gesundheitswesen und
Gesundheitspolitik geht schon immer ein
schwieriges Feld über das ich trefflich
streiten lässt und auf dem sich schon
viele Ministerinnen die Zähne
ausgebissen haben an langfristigen
Lösungen schauen wir ganz schnell und
kurz auf die Vorgänger von Karl
Lauterbach Spahn Gröhe Bar Rösler Ulla
Schmidt Andrea Fischer und Horst
Seehofer maria kleinschmalk ist am Pool
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ich muss mal sagen was für ein
Offenbarungseid 16 Jahre unionsgeführter
Gesundheitspolitik die sie hier
inszeniert haben das ist ja nicht zu
glauben sie haben die große Klagemauer
geführt haben aber vergessen zu nennen
wer eigentlich verantwortlich ist für
das was wir hier an Krise vorfinden und
wir haben natürlich recht sie haben
Recht wir haben an definitiv von 17
Milliarden Euro aus ihrer Wahl aus ihrer
Regierungszeit geerbt wir haben geerbt
einen Haushalt der 0 Vorsorge für diese
Deckung der 17 Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen haben sie haben einen
Wahlkampf geführt anders als wir wo sie
jeder Antwort schuldig geblieben sind
wie sie mit diesem Defizit umgehen
wollen jede Antwort
angesagt dass wir den Menschen zumuten
werden wir haben gesagt wir werden das
gerecht lösen wir haben aber auch gesagt
es wird teurer werden all das haben sie
nicht getan und zusätzlich haben sie 16
Jahre lang vergessen die großen Krisen
im Gesundheitswesen anzugehen und das
das muss ich mal wirklich sagen
krankenhausreform sie haben sie zu Recht
angesprochen zu Recht dieses Problem ist
aber nicht neu sondern es ist ein
altbekanntes als ich 2009 hier im
Bundestag angekommen bin da war selbst
da das schon ein altbekanntes Problem
wir wissen dass wir es mit Versäumnissen
auf der Länderebene zu tun haben und wir
wissen auch dass wir ein
geldentgeltsystem haben auch Bundesebene
das den Erfordernissen nicht gerecht
wird und deshalb meine Lieben Zuhörer
hier deshalb steht die Reform der
krankenhausfin Regierung genau jetzt auf
der Tagesordnung wir gehen Sie an wir
haben innerhalb von wenigen Monaten
haben wir Ergebnisse vorlegen wir haben
Vorschläge vorliegen wir werden als
erstes mit der Pädiatrie umgehen wir
werden als zweites mit der Geburtshilfe
umgehen und wir werden insgesamt die
Krankenhausfinanzierung auf eine neue
Grundlage stellen Frank 1
[Applaus]
und 2 Schritt wir werden natürlich die
krankenhausreform die ist breiter zu
sehen weil wir haben große
Verschränkungen mit den Ländern da
werden wir sie brauchen ich werde sie
erinnern an all das was sie jetzt gerade
gesagt haben weil es wird nicht möglich
sein zu sagen ihr Bund macht mal und wir
Länder halten mal die Hände auf weil wir
brauchen eine vernunftgeleitete eine
wissenschaftlich fundierte
Krankenhausplanung weit entfernt sind
wir derzeit höchstens in NRW kann man
sagen da gibt es diese Schritte wir
brauchen zusätzlich und da kommt der
zweite Punkt eine Reform der Versorgung
insgesamt integrierte Versorgung
kooperierende Versorgung
Gesundheitszentren die gerade in
ländlichen Räumen uns die Versorgung
sichern können da höre ich von Seiten
der CDU nichts außer die große Klage
dass sie sagen wir brauchen mehr
Hausärzte Frau kleinschmeink ich
versuche schon die ganze Zeit eine Lücke
zu finden um die Frage zu stellen
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der cdu/csu-fraktion von
Frau Zollner
sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin vielen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen ich hätte eine
ganz konkrete Frage was tun sie aktuell
um die Krankenhäuser und insgesamt die
soziale Infrastruktur ich denke auch an
die ambulanten Pflegedienste im
ländlichen Raum die mit hohen
Spritkosten umgehen müssen was tun sie
aktuell um dort Entlastungen zu schaffen
bitte ganz konkret was tun sie jetzt
denn jetzt ist dringend Handlung nötig
neben dem sie haben glaube ich den
Minister nicht zugehört und sie haben
auch wahrscheinlich nicht wahrgenommen
dass wir von Seiten der Fraktion
Vorschläge für einen Energie- und
Inflationsschutz hier in dieser Zeit
gemacht haben wir sind in der Diskussion
das wird in den nächsten Wochen
entschieden und da werden wir da werden
wir handeln und ich sag mal eins wir
handeln in dieser Zeit schneller als das
was sie in den ganzen letzten Jahren
gemacht haben und wir werden dafür
sorgen wir werden dafür sorgen dass
unsere wichtige Infrastruktur
unterstützt wird so erhalten wird dass
wir insgesamt daran arbeiten können
zukunftsgerechte Lösungen überhaupt
erstmal zu erstellen das ist doch der
Punkt gestatten sie eine weitere
Zwischenfrage von der Fraktion DIE LINKE
sie reden ja gut eine Frage
ich bin Ihnen ganz besonders dankbar
dass wir auch diese Frage nochmal
zulassen Frau kleinschmank vielen vielen
Dank auch an die Präsidentin ich habe
gerade ihnen zugehört dass sie eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung bei der
Pädiatrie und Geburtshilfe
angehen ich wollte sie an ihren
Koalitionsvertrag erinnern dass da auch
die Notfallversorgung drinsteht und
möchte jetzt fragen weil sie sehr
bewusst oder unbewusst nicht zum ersten
Mal Ausland also nicht sie sondern die
kuration an sich ob sie das Projekt
begraben haben oder ob das auch noch
angehen werden das werden die Kollegen
und Kollegen der Notfallversorgung
nämlich sehr sehr interessieren ob sie
dazuverlässig sind oder nicht
das ist eine sehr gute Frage weil sie
gibt mir dann die Gelegenheit einen
Eindruck der da vielleicht entstanden
sein könnte richtig zu stellen natürlich
gehen wir gerade auch die
Notfallversorgung an das ist der dritte
Punkt den wir als erstes innerhalb der
großen Reform ja angekündigt haben und
jetzt auch angehen werden sie können
sicher sein genau das werden wir tun so
und jetzt kommen wir doch mal dahin was
sind denn eigentlich die Antworten für
die Zukunft wir werden jetzt mit diesem
GKV Finanz
stabilisierungsgesetz können wir nur
einen Übergang schaffen eine einmalige
Lösung weil der Rückgriff auf Reserven
ist nur einmal möglich wir brauchen ganz
klar eine Strukturreform auch bei der
Finanzierung wir haben in der Ampel
wichtige Schritte im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert und auf die
werden wir auch
arbeiten und genau das werden wir tun
und da ist ja auch mal wieder der
springende Punkt sie alle wissen wir
sind jetzt in einer dreifach-krise wir
sind in einer Krise wo wir sehr gut
aufpassen müssen wie viel Belastung
können wir denn eigentlich den einzelnen
Haushalten den einzelnen Versicherten
den Menschen hier im Lande zumuten und
da haben wir einen guten Ausgleich
gefunden zwischen der Belastung über
Anstieg von von Beitragsmitteln wir
haben gleichzeitig hier den den
rücklagenaufbau und wir haben eine
ein effizienzbeitrag den verschiedene
Leistungserbringer bringen werden wir
werden dieses Ziel nicht aus den Augen
verlieren tatsächlich eine Regel
basierte Refinanzierung all der für der
Aufgaben und Ausgaben zu zu installieren
wo es um gesamtgesellschaftliche
Aufgaben geht und da sage ich Ihnen mal
eins 16 Jahre lang haben sie genau das
nicht angepackt sie haben es auch in der
letzten Wahlperiode nicht angezeigt im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag stehen haben dass sie
die Beiträge für die ALG2 beziehenden
anheben werden also steuerfinanziert
anheben werden haben sie nicht gemacht
und das in Zeiten mit höchsten Rücklagen
das ist doch der Punkt und dann haben
sie noch was weiteres gemacht sie haben
die Betriebsrentner freigestellt von
höheren Beiträgen und haben das nicht
refinanziert gemacht sondern uns in
dieser Wahlperiode ebenfalls
übergeholfen so war ihre Art und Weise
Gesundheitspolitik zu machen und da kann
ich nur sagen dass Erbe von der
Ära Jens Spahn war ein sehr sehr teures
und wir gehen das jetzt an und da können
Sie sicher sein und es ist auch ganz
klar
2024 werden wir weitere Schritte gehen
müssen Richtung gerecht dafür
Finanzierung stabiler und
regelgeleiteter gkv-beiträge das werden
wir angehen und das werden da können Sie
sicher sein und da werden wir eben
unseren Beitrag tatsächlich leisten die
Verantwortung für ein stabiles
Gesundheitswesen zu übernehmen das genau
haben sie nicht getan
Maria klein schmalk aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen wo sie
stellvertretende Vorsitzende ist und ich
glaube einen Punkt können wir hier schon
mal festhalten das was Karl Lauterbach
der
Gesundheitsminister in seiner Rede
gesagt hat dass man versuche hier
gemeinsam zu einer Lösung zu kommen ohne
gegenseitige Schuldzuweisungen das
scheint mir dann doch ein wenig verpufft
in dieser Debatte Martin sichert ist ein
Pult gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher der
afd-fraktion und Jens Spahn musste den
Platz auf der Länderbank wieder frei
machen
die Zeit nehmen wir uns dass wir auch
für die bundesratsbank noch mal das
Prozedere erklären dass hier im Hause
nicht fotografiert wird
so und jetzt hat Herr sichert das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
kürzlich traf ich im friesischen Dangast
eine Frau die mit Tränen in den Augen
vor dem Schwimmbad stand diese Frau
weinte weil sie es sich finanziell
schlicht nicht leisten kann mit ihren
Kindern ins Schwimmbad zu gehen während
Ukrainer kostenlosen Eintritt haben
dieses Beispiel zeigt exemplarisch was
in Deutschland schief läuft während
ukrainische Nobelkarossen vor deutschen
Zahnarztpraxen stehen und nur keiner
sich auf Kosten der deutschen
Beitragszahler die Zähne richten lassen
wissen viele Deutsche nicht mehr wie sie
angesichts der gestiegenen
Lebenshaltungskosten selbst ihre
Grundnahrungsmittel finanzieren sollen
dass die Ukrainer diese Leistungen
annehmen das kann man ihnen nicht
vorwerfen der Fehler liegt einzig und
allein bei der deutschen Regierung die
auf dem Rücken der einheimischen
Bevölkerung Ausländern ein kostenloses
rundum Sorglos-Paket anbietet das ein
Ukrainer der mit der Mercedes S-Klasse
vorfährt mehr staatliche Unterstützung
bekommt als eine deutsche
alleinerziehende Mutter ist irre dass
jemand der nicht arbeiten geht
finanziell besser dasteht als jemand der
Vollzeit arbeitet ist irre dass man
wegen angeblicher Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser die Menschen zur Maske
zwingt und zum Impfen nötigt aber
zugleich zulässt dass zahllosen
Krankenhäusern wegen der Energiekosten
die Insolvenz droht ist irre diese
gesamte Politik ist irre
sie weigern sich beharrlich die Ursachen
der Probleme anzugehen die einzige
Lösung die sie kennen ist immer mehr
Geld der Steuerzahler um zu verteilen
sie treiben damit das Land in die
Inflationen die Bürger massenhaft in die
Armut schlimmer noch sie bestrafen
konsequent Leistung genauso wie sie mit
dem Bürgergeld jeden bestrafen der
fleißig ist und arbeiten geht bestrafen
Sie mit diesem Gesetz alle Krankenkassen
die solide gewirtschaftet haben sie
nennen das stabilisierungsgesetz aber in
Wahrheit destabilisieren sie die Kassen
indem sie die vorhandenen Reserven
einiger Kassen sozialistisch umverteilen
sie sind leistungsfeindliche Sozialisten
wer anständig und vernünftig arbeitet
der ist bei ihnen der Dumme und die FDP
die präsentiert sich hier einmal mehr
als reiner Alibi Wurmfortsatz für
rot-grüne Spinnereien sie machen
inzwischen alles mit und haben jede
Position diese mal im Wahlkampf
vertreten haben vollkommen aufgegeben
neben der Massenverarmung der
Bevölkerung durch immer mehr Inflation
und staatliche Umverteilung sehen sie
auch der Zerstörung des deutschen
Gesundheitswesens tatenlos zu zahllosen
Krankenhäusern Reha-Einrichtungen
Physiotherapeuten droht durch die
gestiegenen Energiekosten und die
Inflation die Insolvenz sie reden hier
von Stabilisierung zur wirklich
notwendigen Stabilisierung im
Gesundheitswesen legen sie aber
keinerlei Ansatz vor das ist absolut
unverantwortlich
mit ihrer Politik haben Sie alles in
Schieflage gebracht es ist höchste Zeit
Deutschland wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße
zu stellen hören wir auf jedem illegal
eingereisten und jedem Ukraine ein
rundum Sorglos-Paket zum Nulltarif zur
Verfügung zu stellen beenden wir den
Grünen extremistischen Wahnsinn der sich
Energiewende nennt und sorgen wir für
bezahlbare Energie für jedermann und
sorgen wir für
alt verfügbare und bezahlbare
Arzneimittel indem wir die Produktion in
Deutschland und Europa stärken das wäre
vernünftig und gut und das wäre
Ursachenbekämpfung
[Applaus]
hier hier vorgelegtes Gedankengut des
leistungsfeindlichen Sozialismus ist das
leider nicht
übrigens die eingangs erwähnte
alleinerziehende Mutter wählt in zwei
Wochen bei der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen AFD weil wir als einzige
eine vernünftige Politik vertreten wie
sie in über 90 Prozent der Länder
weltweit normal ist ich hoffe das machen
viele Menschen vielleicht kommen sie
dann mal zum Nachdenken herzlichen Dank
Martin sichert aus der afd-fraktion mit
einer na sagen wir mal sehr besonderen
Sicht auf Ukrainerinnen die sich derzeit
in Deutschland aufhalten aufhalten
müssen sollte man vielleicht ergänzen
Andrew Ullmann ist der nächste Redner
aus der FDP-Fraktion
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren es ist gut dass in der
letzten Bundesregierung Olaf Scholz für
die Staatsfinanzen zuständig war und
nicht jemand aus der Union sonst sehe
unser Bundeshaushalt so aus wie die
gkv-finanzen wir Studenten vor einem
Scherbenhaufen
um es klar zu sagen
dieses Gesetz brauchen wir auch keine
Freude es ist keine Freude nämlich
höhere Zusatzbeiträge zu erheben ist es
kein gutes Gefühl zu Leistungserbringer
zu gehen und zu sagen dass wir trotz
ihrer hochwertig erbrachten
medizinischen Leistungen Einsparungen
vornehmen müssen
aber was ist die Alternative
ohne ein Gesetz wie dieses würden die
beitragszahlerinnen und Zahler im
kommenden Jahr Beitragssteigerungen von
mehrere hundert Euro erleben
es ist nicht verantwortbar und so etwas
ist nicht verantwortbar in Zeiten von
Inflation und Energiekrise
es ist daher richtig dass wir die
Finanzierungslücke von 17 Milliarden
Euro im kommenden Jahr nun angehen eine
Zahl die uns nicht überrascht und seit
einiger Zeit im Raume steht der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat erste gute
Vorschläge unterbreitet und ich bedanke
mich auch an dieser Stelle ausdrücklich
bei unserem Finanzminister der ist der
ASS eine Erhöhung des Bundeszuschusses
trotz der sehr angespannten
Haushaltslage zugestimmt hat
zudem bin ich auch froh dass die
geplante rückwirkend erhobene Solidar
Beitrag für pharmazeutische Unternehmen
im Kabinettsbeschluss sich nicht mehr
wiederfindet bei dieser Regelung halte
ich ordnungspolitische Bedenken
angemeldet es ist gut dass die
Bundesregierung das überarbeitet hat
zudem ist es mir auch wichtig dass wir
von der FDP im vorliegenden Entwurf den
Antrag zu Strukturreformen im
Gesundheitswesen gesetzlich verankert
haben die Defizite in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung werden in den
kommenden Jahren nicht weniger aufgrund
der Alterung der Gesellschaft und der
angespannten wirtschaftlichen Situation
werden die Einnahmen voraussichtlich
geringer und die Ausgaben werden weiter
steigen ja meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich eine
ausgabenpublik ein Ausgabenproblem denn
die Fehlanreize im Gesundheitssystem
sorgen für ein teures aber wenig
effizientes System
da müssen wir gemeinsam an die
Strukturen ran um die Kosten im Griff zu
behalten
es geht bei dieser Entwicklung das große
Ganze es geht darum ob eine
Krankenversicherung dessen
Leistungsspektrum staatlich organisiert
wird funktionieren kann die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung steht vor allem
wegen dem politischen Management
schlechter da als die private
Krankenversicherung
die private Krankenversicherung Dingen
mit ihrem Finanzierungssystem mit der
Bildung von Rücklagen an die Zukunft
die Umlagefinanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenkasse ist in Zeiten des
demografischen Wandels nicht mehr auf
der Höhe der Zeit ich halte es trotzdem
für unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe die
Zukunft der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung zu sichern dafür ist
dieses Gesetz ein erster Schritt aber
sicherlich meine Damen und Herren nicht
der letzte
dabei geht es nicht nur um
Strukturreformen innerhalb des
Abrechnungssystems sollen reformsysteme
die die CDU CSU nicht getraut haben in
den Jahren der Regierungszeit anzugehen
unsere fortschrittskoalition in der
Ampel hat uns ambitionierte Ziele
gesetzt Ziele die ein dringliche
Umsetzung bedürfen denn anders werden
unsere Erwartungen in ein gutes
Gesundheitssystem scheitern
meine Damen und Herren unser
Gesundheitssystem muss menschlicher
digitaler ambulanter vernetzter
bedarfsgerechter und innovativer werden
und für die Leistungserbringer wird das
System auskömmlich finanziert sein das
GKV finanzstabilisierungsgesetz ist ein
erster notwendiger aber schmerzlicher
Schritt doch die nächsten wichtigen
Reformschritte sind bereits
vorgezeichnet so machen wir unser
Gesundheitssystem resilienter und
zukunftssicher für alle und ich freue
mich auf die Diskussion in unserem
Ausschuss herzlichen Dank
Andrew Ullmann aus der FDP-Fraktion wo
er gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher ist
und ihm folgt jetzt arktisch aus der
Linksfraktion da ist ja Sprecher für
Krankenhaus und pflegepolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Minister sie haben gesagt wir
sollten nicht polemisch werden ich darf
irgendwie daran erinnern dass sie mit
der Politik angefangen haben indem wir
das Gesetz finanzstabilisierungsgesetz
genannt haben ich glaube das ist die
erste Polemik die sie sich geleistet
haben und müssen mit manchen leider auch
üblen Reaktionen dann rechnen ich möchte
anfangen mit dem Problem der Schätzung
das erste von sie ausgehen sie sagen es
geht um 17 Milliarden Euro dem nächsten
Jahr fehlen werden ich möchte daran
erinnern dass das sehr niedrig gerechnet
ist es gibt andere berechnungsinstitut
für Gesundheit und Sozialforschung hat
von 24,6 Milliarden Euro ist von 24,6
Milliarden Euro ausgegangen und das war
im Juni diesen Jahres da war sozusagen
die Kosten hier im Winter auf die ganzen
leistungsbringerinnen der Bringer
zukommen noch gar nicht drin die ganzen
Krankenhäuser Pflege die quasi von den
die sehr energiekostenreich sind und die
ganzen Energiekosten tragen müssen
diesen da noch gar nicht berücksichtigt
deswegen sind auch gegen 17 Milliarden
definitiv zu wenig diese Zahlen werden
nicht ausreichen und deswegen ist das
was sie da beschreiben Polemik weil sie
schon vom viel zu geringen Betrag
ausgehend müssen
und das Problem ist aber was ihr gerade
benannt haben wie das Ganze stabilisiert
werden soll sie behaupten die ganze Zeit
das kommt eben nicht so sehr auf die
beitragszahlerinnen Beitragszahler zu
der Spitzenverband der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung die das anders der
geht von 11 von diesen 17 Milliarden
Euro aus der eigentlich bei den
Beitragszahlen landet landet warum zum
einen die Anhebung und von Ihnen
genannten 0,3 Prozent sind in diesem
Winter übrigens schon eine beachtliche
Summe weil es nicht das einzige ist was
auf die Menschen zukommt und ich darf
nur mal daran erinnern dass die
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung vor
allem von den mittelverdienenden und
geringverdienen geleistet werden weil
die Höhe verdienen dort gar nicht
einzahlen unter anderem auch einige von
ihnen nicht das heißt also das geht vor
allem an den an an ans Geld jetzt schon
nur noch allzu wenig haben das
eigentliche Problem ist aber und das
wird dann wirklich absurd dass sie
selbst beschreiben dass die Lasten auf
verschiedenen Schultern verteilt werden
müssen und nicht ich zitiere allein den
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
auferlegt werden können und dann
schreiben so sind auf der Einnahmenseite
neben höheren Bundesmitteln auch die
Finanzreserven der Krankenkassen
hinzuzuziehen nun möchte ich Sie fragen
wie die Reserven eigentlich woher die
Reserven dieser Krankenkassen eigentlich
kommen wenn nicht von den
beitragszahlenden Herr Lauterbach die
haben diese Reserven nämlich mit
aufgebaut und deswegen ist der
Spitzenverband der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung richtig in der
Ansicht zu sagen dass Elf von 17
Milliarden von den gesetzlich
Versicherten geleistet werden direkt
oder indirekt nun könnten wir eine große
Lösung vorschlagen endlich eine
solidarische Gesundheitsversicherung zu
machen das wäre dringend nötig sie
schreiben ja auch ganz schön dass es
alles solidarisch geleitet werden soll
auch wenn sie selbst nicht tun
wir haben auch eine kleine Lösung
vorgeschlagen die sie jetzt angehen
könnten die sie einfach übernehmen
könnten wir haben Anträge eingereicht
die weitaus mehr Geld zur Verfügung
stehen würden wenn sie das annehmen
würden dass das was sie vorschlagen zum
einen wollen wir die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze nicht sofort
auflösen das natürlich unser Ziel
sondern zunächst mal Anhebung anheben
auf das Niveau der Rentenversicherung
West das heißt es gibt eine Anhebung das
betrifft dann nicht ihre Geringverdiener
die mehr zahlen müssen das betrifft er
nicht die mittelverdienenden die jetzt
im Winter schon nicht mehr über die
Runden kommen sondern das betrifft
tatsächlich diejenigen die jetzt gut
verdienen das Punkt eins das wären
12,65 Milliarden Euro dieser mit mehr in
der Tasche hätten das wäre das eine der
zweite Punkt und ich bin ja glaube ich
selten in der Holidaycheck auch obwohl
auch aus Bayern aber da einer Meinung
warum sie die Beitragszahlungen der ALG2
beziehenden durch den Bund nicht
reformieren das werden weitere 2,6
Milliarden Euro um dies jetzt gehen
würde das können Sie jetzt gewonnen und
drittens wir reden ja auch von der
Reduzierung der Mehrwertsteuer das hat
er nicht immer Sinn gemacht wenn wir
beiden Arzneimittel aber den mäßigten
Mehrwertsteuersatz anwenden würden dann
wäre das weil es ein sehr stark
regulierter Markt wäre tatsächlich etwas
was bei den Erbringern ankommen würde
das wären weitere 5 Milliarden Euro all
das haben wir einen Anträgen vorgelegt
setzen Sie sie um dann wird es auch
weniger polemisch wenn sie den Titel von
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz nicht wird
dann müssen den Titel
finanzstabilisierung jetzt nicht mehr
ändern um selbst nicht problemig zu sein
vielen vielen Dank
hinaus der Linksfraktion Krankenhaus und
pflegepolitischer Sprecher und jetzt
kommt für die SPD Christos pantazis dr
med übrigens der neurobionik und wenn
sie jetzt Fragezeichen im Gesicht haben
muss ich sie mit den kurz alleine lassen
von Kollegen eine Krise jagt die nächste
selten hat eine Redewendung unsere Zeit
so treffend beschrieben wie diese
corona-pandemie Klimawandel und nicht
zuletzt der russische Angriffskrieg mit
drastisch gestiegenen Energiepreisen und
hohen Inflationsraten haben zu einem
Konjunktureinbruch in Deutschland
geführt diese Entwicklung setzt sich
auch die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
unter Druck seit Jahren wachsen hier die
Ausgaben mit jährlich rund vier
Prozentpunkten spürbar stärker als die
Einnahmen wesentlicher Grund dafür ist
ein anhaltender Reformstau infolgedessen
sehen wir uns mit einer
milliardenschweren Defizit konfrontiert
das allein im nächsten Jahr 17
Milliarden Euro betragen soll 17
Milliarden das ist genau die Zahl des
Tages über die wir im Rahmen des
heutigen ersten Lesung des
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetzes
beraten und die es im kommenden Jahr
kurzfristig zu schließen gilt Herr
Minister ich will in diesem Zusammenhang
nicht verhehlen dass ich es ihnen hoch
anrechne ihren Amtsvorgänger hierfür
nicht zu kritisieren aber zur Wahrheit
gehört auch ihr Vorgänger im Amt hat
seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht und
Ihnen dieses Defizit sprichwörtlich
vererbt
ihr Vorgänger im Amt hat es trotz
wirtschaftlich guter Rahmenbedingungen
nicht vermocht Strukturreform
entschieden anzugehen sondern sich viel
mehr auf populäre allerdings teure
leistungsreform konzentriert die uns
jetzt auf die Füße fallen deswegen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union wird es gelinde gesagt etwas
wohlfall nun aus der Position heraus
welche Mensch Strukturreform
einzufordern und nach Jahren der
Blockade sich unser nachhaltigen
finanzierungsvorschlägen anzueignen
Pferdekollegen Kollegen obwohl wir die
Finanzen der gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
in einem sehr schwierigen Zustand
vorgefunden haben es ist ja vorhin eben
gerade auch schon erläutert worden
bekennt sich die forschungskoalition
auch weiterhin ich zitiere gern aus der
Koalitionsvereinbarung zu einer stabilen
und verlässlichen Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
das von der Bundesregierung hier
vorgelegte GKV
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz begrüßen wir
von der Stoßrichtung her denn ohne
kurzfristig greifende Maßnahmen müssen
die Zusatzbeiträge im kommenden Jahren
von derzeit durchschnittlich 1,3 Prozent
um rund ein Prozent steigen in
Anbetracht ansteigender Energiepreise
sowie hoher Inflationsraten wäre das für
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
schlichtweg Gift und könnte für private
Haushalte womöglich die Grenze der
Belastbarkeit beschreiben insofern sieht
der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf vor die
Lasten solidarisch auf mehrere Schultern
zu verteilen so sollen beitragsreserven
von Kassen und Gesundheitsfond
herangezogen aber auch ein erhöhter
Bundeszuschuss sowie Italiener die GKV
gewährt werden im Rahmen von
Effizienzverbesserung werden neben der
Pharmaindustrie auch Apotheken
Zahnärztinnen und Ärztinnen ihren
Beitrag zur Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung leisten
müssen diese Lastenverteilung ermöglicht
es Zusatzbeiträge lediglich in einer
moderaten Rahmen in Höhe von 0,3
Prozentpunkten zu erhöhen der hier
vorliegende Entwurf verfolgt also das
Ziel die gkv-finanzen zu stabilisieren
ohne dabei auf Leistungskürzungen
zurückgreifen zu müssen was ich für
meine Fraktion ausdrücklich begrüße
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
dem mit diesem vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf wird ein kurzfristiger
Ausgleich des Defizits von 17 Milliarden
Euro erreicht die fortschrittskoalition
vertritt allerdings den Anspruch die
gkv-finanzen langfristig verlässlich und
somit krisenfest aufzustellen um diesem
Anspruch gerecht zu werden halten wir
tiefgreifende Strukturreformen
Gesundheitssystem für unumgänglich von
der Krankenhausfinanzierung über die
ambulantisierung bis hin zur
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen in
der Pflege werden wir Reformvorhaben
anhand unserer Koalitionsvereinbarung
sukzessive abarbeiten denselben Anspruch
liegt meine Fraktion wenn es um die
nachhaltige Finanzierung der GKV geht
auch hier werden wir uns an den
Leitplanken des Koalitionsvertrages
orientieren das schließt ausdrücklich
die regelhafte Dynamisierung des
Bundeszuschusses sowie höhere Beiträge
für die Beziehungen und Bezieher von
Arbeitslosengeld II aus Steuermitteln
mit ein
meine Fraktion strebt weiterhin eine
ausgewogene Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung an
dabei spielt auch die Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze eine gewichtige
Rolle
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
komme zum Schluss das Wesen der
parlamentarischen Demokratie ist der
Kompromiss und in Zeiten wo eine Krise
die nächste Jagd muss der
Parlamentarismus genau hier durch seine
Handlungsfähigkeit unter Beweis stellen
schließlich geht es um nicht weniger als
die zentrale Säule unseres
Solidarsystems die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung diese gilt es zu
stützen und die Lasten dabei gerecht zu
verteilen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
Christos patatis aus der SPD-Fraktion
und falls Sie es nicht gerade selber
nachgeguckt haben neurobionik ist die
Verbindung von Neurologie Biologie und
Technik geht natürlich auch noch viel
komplizierter aber lassen wir es mal
dabei Tino Sorge ist ja nicht so Redner
in dieser Debatte er ist
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion an dem Punkt wo wir
darüber diskutieren wie wir das
gesetzliche Versicherungssystem die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
zukunftsfest machen können und da bin
ich bin ich jedes mal wieder total
irritiert wenn Sie sich hier aus der
Ampelkoalition insbesondere die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der SPD
hinstellen und so tun als hätten sie die
letzten Jahre hier überhaupt nicht
mitregiert liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen also ich darf nur noch mal dran
erinnern wir waren sie haben 23 Jahre
dieses Land mitregiert 23 Jahre wir
haben in der letzten Legislatur auf
ausdrücklichen Wunsch und gemeinsam auch
auf Kunst von Herrn
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
viele gute Dinge auf den Weg gebracht
ich darf nur an die Verbesserung in der
Pflege erinnern ich darf an die neue
patientenregelung ändern ich darf an die
Verbesserung beim bei der Zahngesundheit
erinnern und das erste was Sie jetzt tun
an Vorschlägen hier zu machen für die
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung ist diese guten
Regelung wieder zurückzutreten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und da wundern
sie sich da wundern sie sich allen
Ernstes lieber Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das unisono
alle Akteure dieses Gesundheitssystems
sagen das geht so nicht ich darf nur mal
zitieren der Vorsitzende des Gemeinsamen
Bundesausschusses das ist ja relativ
selten so deutlich zu Wort
äußert hat gesagt bei diesem
Gesetzentwurf handelt es sich um ein
völlig sinnloses Sammelsurium Zitat Ende
und ich darf noch mal darauf hinweisen
mein Bundesland Sachsen-Anhalt da haben
gestern 20 Akteure des gesamten
Gesundheitssystems von Ärzten
Krankenkassen bis hin zum Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbund ein gemeinsamer relles
Resolution auf den Weg gebracht in der
sie sagen in dieser Form geht das nicht
das liegt die Axt an die Wurzel unseres
Gesundheit und spätestens da lieber Herr
Kollege Lauterbach liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel sollten bei Ihnen die
Alarmglocken ganz laut schrillen
und deshalb Frau Kollegin kleinschmeich
hören Sie endlich auf sie regieren seit
fast einem Jahr hier kommen nur
Konjunktive Sie möchten Sie werden sie
sollten wo ist denn die Unterstützung
die Soforthilfe für die Kliniken wo ist
denn die Unterstützung wir haben vor der
Sommerpause als Unionsfraktion einen
Antrag vorgelegt indem wir gefordert
haben aufgrund der extrem gestiegenen
energiepreiskosten die Kliniken zu
unterstützen nichts passiert sie treiben
die Kliniken in den Insolvenz und wenn
sie da jetzt nicht zeitnah nachlegen
passiert gar nichts Finanzreform Pflege
auf 2023 verschoben
krankenhauskommission lieber Kollege
Lauterbach wir haben es in den
Kommission eingesetzt die Kommission
wird ein Langzeitprojekt keine
Ergebnisse insofern handeln sie endlich
und kommen sie aus dem ankündigungsmodus
raus liebe Kolleginnen keine Sorge
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage von der
Kollegin klein schmeink
Herr Kollege Tino Sorge sie haben eine
ganze Reihe von Problemen angesprochen
die wir ja alle geerbt haben aus der
letzten Wahlperiode und was haben Sie
denn unternommen um eine grundlegende
krankenhausstrukturreform auf den Weg zu
bringen gemeinsam mit ihrem Kollegen
Herrn Minister holitschek was haben Sie
denn unternommen um zum Beispiel die
ländliche Versorgung tatsächlich zu
stabilisieren und voranzubringen was
haben sie unternommen um die
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
Gesundheitsberufen so zu stärken dass
wir auch tatsächlich nach vorne
gerichtet die Versorgung sicherstellen
können Sie zählen hier viele Dinge auf
haben an ganz vielen Punkten
beispielsweise auch nicht gesagt wie
finanzieren Sie das denn jetzt und das
würde ich ganz gerne von Ihnen hören
erstens warum hat es diese grundlegende
krankenhaus- um im Zusammenspiel mit den
Ländern bisher nicht gegeben zweitens
was tun sie bezogen auf die
Zusammenarbeit der Gesundheitsberufe was
haben sie da getan was wirklich
voranbringt und drittens wie finanzieren
Sie genau diese Lücke sie klagen halt
hier jetzt nur darüber aber was machen
Sie denn ganz konkret zur Refinanzierung
ich habe noch nichts Schriftliches von
ihnen gesehen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin kleinschweig
das gibt mir die Möglichkeit noch mal
detailliert auf die ganzen
Gesetzesvorhaben die wir in den letzten
Legislaturen gemacht haben auf den Weg
auf den Weg nicht nur zu bringen sondern
ihn noch mal zu erklären sie waren ja
offensichtlich häufig nicht da wir haben
erstens in der Pflege Pflegeberufe
reformgesetzt wir haben die Ausbildung
in der Pflege reformiert wir haben die
Leistung für Pflegebedürftige für die
Angehörige reformiert wir haben in einem
großen gesellschaftlichen Konsens
zusätzlich Geld ins System gegeben haben
erstmals für Alzheimer erkrankte
beispielsweise dass sie überhaupt
erstmal Anspruch auf Pflegeleistung
haben immer wir haben im
Krankenhausbereich Krankenhaus
Zukunftsfonds Milliarden auf den Weg
gebracht damit Digitalisierung
vorangetrieben wird wir haben drei große
digitalisierungsgesetz gemacht ich frag
mich wo sie in der Zeit hier waren wenn
das alles an ihm vorbeigegangen liebe
Frau Kollegin
und jetzt jetzt hören Sie jetzt hören
Sie endlich auf immer so zu tun als
hätten sie nie politische Verantwortung
getragen das ist ja in jedem Bereich
mittlerweile so dass sie so tun als
hätten sie nie hier irgendwie im
Bundestag gesessen sie müssen endlich
auch mal pragmatisch jetzt Lösung
vorlegen und nicht immer nur ankündigen
und sagen sie werden sie wollen und Sie
möchten und ich sage Ihnen auch ganz
klar wenn sie dann schon Vorschläge
vorlegen dann tun sie doch wenigstens
das was im Koalitionsvertrag schreiben
da schreiben sie ja durchaus an der ein
oder anderen Stelle gute Sachen das ist
angesprochen worden zehn Milliarden
würde das System entlastet werden wenn
sie erstmal in der richtigen Höhe die
Beiträge für ALG2 Bezieher abführen
würden es gibt eine Menge Vorschläge
aber jetzt die neue patientenregelung
zurückzudrehen wo Patienten viel
schneller das erste Mal Termin beim
Facharzt bekommen haben die sich jetzt
beschweren wo die Ärzte sagen sie haben
Personal eingestellt was sie wieder
entlassen müssten hören Sie doch auf
dieser Regelung zurückzudrehen die eher
marginale Summen einsparen sondern gehen
Sie die strukturellen Probleme an liebe
Frau Kollegin klein Liebe Ampelkoalition
und deshalb recht es sich jetzt dass
sich der
Bundesgesundheitsminister der
Bundesfinanzminister der
Bundesjustizminister nicht über den Weg
trauen klaus holletschek hat sie
angesprochen es kann doch nicht sein
dass der Bundesgesundheitsminister jedes
Mal bei jedem strukturellen Vorhaben
sagt ich muss da erstmal Christian
Lindner Fragen und der dann sagt ich
habe das mit Karl Lauterbach ganz anders
besprochen das ist doch die bankrotte
Erklärung für Gesundheitspolitik in
diesem Land
und deshalb sage ich Ihnen ganz klar
machen sie nicht solche Murks wie bei
der gasumlage denken Sie jetzt schnell
an die Kliniken sonst gehen viele
Kliniken im Herbst in die Insolvenz das
wird zu Versorgungsengpässen führen das
haben die Patienten nicht verdient das
haben die Leistungserbringer nicht
verdient und vor allen Dingen noch ein
Wort zum Schluss lieber Herr Kollege
Lauterbach wenn sie schon mit vielen
Worten den Akteuren im System danken
wenn sie sagen Danke liebe Ärzte danke
Apotheker danke Pflegekräfte dass wir
mit euch so gut durch diese Pandemie
gekommen sind vielen Dank innovatives
Pharmaindustrie dann ist es für diese
Menschen mittlerweile ein Huhn wenn sie
als erste Maßnahme dann sagen wir machen
Preismoratorium wir kürzen es gibt
weniger Geld Apothekenabschlag also
diese Leute empfinden das als
Leistungskürzung und hier zu sagen es
gäbe keine Leistungskürzung entspricht
nicht der Wahrheit vielen herzlichen
Dank
dinosäure gesundheitspolitischer
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion hat jetzt
gar nicht erwähnt die Vorschläge seines
Fraktionskollegen Sepp Müller der ja
eingeregt hatte die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anzuheben sowie
die Versicherungspflichtgrenze das würde
bedeuten dass die berühmten stärkeren
Schulter auch stärker beteiligt wären an
den Einnahmen der Krankenkassen jetzt
janoschen Damen für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen
anderweitig zuschauen die Debatte die
wir hier erleben ist von einigen aus
diesem Hause in einem Maße unredlich
geführt was wirklich seinesgleichen
sucht ich muss sagen das eine ist eine
Fehlerkultur hier in den letzten Tagen
hinzulegen die bei jedem Mal wenn es
darum geht was in der Vergangenheit
nicht richtig gelaufen ist mit Gejohle
zu reagieren und einfach so zu tun als
sei es vergessen und nicht den Hauch
einer Demut an den Tag zu legen für
Dinge die falsch gelaufen sind und die
jetzt korrigiert werden müssen das
andere
das andere und das ist viel schlimmer
ist eine Oppositionsarbeit zu betreiben
die offensichtlich sich jeder
Rechenschaft entleert wie denn
Vorschläge mit der Situation die jetzt
nun mal vorzufinden ist umgegangen
werden sollen mit Vorschlägen wie denn
die 17 Milliarden die als Defizit in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung liegen
wie diese aufgelöst werden sollen ich
habe nicht gehört dass aus den
unionsreihen die Aufhebung der
Schuldenbremse gefordert wird ich habe
nicht gehört dass sie fordern dass die
Beiträge für die Menschen in diesem Land
in einem Maße angeheben werden soll die
keiner in diesem Wind da stemmen kann
ich habe nicht gehört dass sie fordern
das Leistungskürzung im Gesundheitswesen
in Ersatz zu diesem Defizit durchgeführt
werden sollen und sich einfach
hinzustellen ohne ein Hauch eines
Vorschlags zu sagen wie das Defizit
aufgelöst werden soll das ist bei allen
Fehlern der Vergangenheit heute
unredliche Oppositionsarbeit und ich
muss Ihnen sagen das hätten wir uns
nicht
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Zwischenbemerkung von dem Kollegen Sorge
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
ja vielen Dank lieber Herr Kollege Damen
dass sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen mich
würde ganz konkret interessieren werden
sie das was sie im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben nämlich die zehn
Milliarden an Zahlungen für
alg2-bezieher auch dem Gesundheitssystem
zur Verfügung stellen zeitnah umsetzen
und mich würde vor allen Dingen
interessieren ob Sie der Meinung sind
dass jetzt die Abschmelzung der
kassenreserven ob das da sie ja im
Vorfeld durch die Versicherten
aufgebracht worden sind keine
Leistungskürzung bzw
Beitragssatzerhöhung indirekt darstellen
vielen Dank für die Frage Herr Kollege
Sorge ich will ihnen darauf antworten
also erstens selbstverständlich werden
wir den Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen und
das beinhaltet auch dass wir die
Beiträge für ALG2 versichert in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung auf das
Notwendige finanzierungsmaß anheben
werden wir werden auch den
Bundeszuschuss dynamisieren um ein
ordnungspolitischen Automatismus da drin
zu haben wie Finanzierung funktioniert
und nicht durch eine Serie an
digitalreform die unstrukturiert ohne
digitalstrategie ein Riesenloch
beispielsweise gerissen haben jetzt mit
dazu beitragen dass wir hier solch ein
Finanzierungsdefizit haben zweiter Punkt
ihrer Frage ich bin nicht der
Überzeugung dass wir in Zeiten Multipla
Krisen irgendwo in der Ecke Reserven
liegen lassen können die wir brauchen um
die Not die in diesem Land Existenz ist
abzufedern insofern ist es richtig jeder
der Beteiligten
Stakeholder im Gesundheitswesen
aufzufordern zu sagen wie können wir
gemeinsam einen Beitrag leisten genau
das tut das Gesetz indem wir eben nicht
sagen es gibt einen der beteiligten
Seiten die alles schultern muss sondern
bei den gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
bei den Krankenhäusern im Bereich der
niedergelassenen Ärzte und der
Krankenversicherung gemeinsam schauen
wie ein Beitrag geleistet werden kann um
das Problem zu beheben das ist
verantwortliche Politik und ich will
ihnen sagen in der Opposition wir sind
immer zu den unseren Haushältern
gegangen und haben die Refinanzierung
von kritikvorschlägen hier im Parlament
vorher abstimmen müssen ich glaube es
war bei der FDP nicht anders und ich
kann sagen so ist verantwortliche
Oppositionsarbeit aber zu Unredlichkeit
Herr Damm ich habe noch eine
Zwischenfrage von der Kollegin Vogler
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
Herr Kollege dass sie meine
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie haben ja
gerade gesagt dass sie über die
Schuldenbremse diskutieren wollen das
finde ich auch sehr sehr richtig da sind
wir als LINKE voll bei Ihnen die
Schuldenbremse hindert uns daran aber
wir brauchen ja für die Stabilisierung
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
eigentlich keine Sondervermögen zu
erheben sondern wir haben ja ganz
konkrete als konstruktive
Oppositionsfraktion ganz konkrete
Vorschläge auf den Tisch gelegt für die
eigentlich auch eine Mehrheit hier im
Hause möglich wäre sowohl Maria
kleinschmain von ihrer Fraktion
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
als auch der Kollege Brand Harzes von
der SPD als auch sogar der
stellvertretende
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende Sepp Müller
haben ja genau das gefordert was wir in
unserem Antrag zur Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze und der
Pflichtversicherungsgrenze fordern und
ich frage mich dann schon wie lange
wollen wir uns hier die offensichtlich
eine politische Mehrheit hätten um diese
sehr gute Idee um Essen die tatsächlich
das leisten kann was Karl Lauterbach ja
gefordert hat nämlich starke Schultern
mehr tragen zu lassen als schwache wenn
wir diese Möglichkeit haben warum
kämpfen wir nicht darum dafür auch hier
eine parlamentarische Mehrheit zu
bekommen statt uns vom Förderverein der
privatversicherungsunternehmen auch
vulgo FDP
hier an der Nase herumführen zu lassen
vielen dank vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Vogler zunächst mal möchte ich Ihnen und
Ihrer Fraktion zu gut erhalten dass sie
im Gegensatz zur Union konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht haben was man denn
tun kann wenngleich auch die Frage der
refinanzierbarkeit nicht in all den
Vorschlägen hinterlegt ist will ich doch
wohl sagen dass wir wie eben angedeutet
selbstverständlich im Verlauf der
Legislatur weitergehende umfassendere
strukturelle Reformen im Bereich der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
einschließlich der Diskussion Anhebung
der alg2-sätze Dynamisierung
Bundeszuschuss und auch der Frage der
Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze miteinander
beraten und auch beschließen werden
insofern zu sagen dass diese Reform das
letzte und abschließende Wort zur
Weiterentwicklung und Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung ist
wäre falsch und insofern begreifen sie
dies als einen ersten Schritt der von
weiteren sehr viel umfassenden Reformen
im kommenden Jahr gefolgt werden wird
lassen Sie mich fortfahren
beim Thema Unredlichkeit kann ich es mir
nicht verkneifen einmal auf den
bayerischen Gesundheitsminister
holitschek reagieren zu müssen ich muss
schon sagen dass sie sich hier
hinstellen und so tun als hätten wir
nicht Eckle ein eklatantes Problem im
Bereich der
investitionskostenfinanzierung überall
und auch ausdrücklich in Bayern da
gehört schon einiges dazu das wissen sie
doch alle in Verantwortung in den
Ländern beispielsweise bei ihnen in
Bayern ist es nicht so dass sie sich
hier hinstellen können und einfach eine
Zahl mit sechs Stellen hier in den Raum
werfen damit das so klingt als sei das
viel wenn es faktisch mit dem realen
Wertverlust doch bedeutet dass sie seit
1991 40 Prozent weniger
Investitionskosten im Bereich ihrer
Krankenhauslandschaft ausgegeben haben
und hat das was mit unserer realen
Situation jetzt zu tun na
selbstverständlich die fehlenden
Investitionskosten führen dazu dass
jedes Krankenhausbett bei ihnen in
Bayern so viel Energie verbraucht wie
ein Einfamilienhaus mit meiner ganzen
fünfköpfigen Familie das führt dazu dass
die Not der Kliniken im Moment so groß
ist dass die Kosten so stark steigen und
dass wir jenseits dieses Gesetzes
selbstverständlich weitere
Rettungsmaßnahmen für die stationäre
Versorgung auf den Weg bringen müssen
und jetzt zu sagen jetzt zu sagen dass
nicht in einem einzigen Gesetz die
gesamten Probleme der Gesundheitspolitik
aufgelöst werden ja was ist denn das für
ein Politikverständnis immer nur zu
zeigen der moment mal hier liegt ein
Vorschlag vor aber es gibt auch noch
andere Probleme zu denen ist nichts
gesagt worden das ist doch keine Politik
das ist doch einfach nur marktschreierei
und Ablenkung gehen Sie doch auf die
Vorschläge ein bringen sie Alternativen
ein sagen Sie dieses refinanzieren
wollen und sind sie ehrlich zu den
Menschen erzählen sie nicht vor einer
Wahl es gibt kein Problem wenn 17
Milliarden fehlen sondern sagen Sie was
bedeutet das und inzwischen haben wir
multiple Krisen auf die wir reagieren
müssen und ich will Ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen wir tun wir tun das sehr
verantwortungsvoll indem wir mit allen
Seiten sprechen dass jeder zunächst mal
sagt ich kann nichts geben weil Brot bei
mir groß ist ist doch selbstverständlich
in diesen Zeiten das heißt aber nicht
dass wir uns nicht alle zusammenstehen
müssen einen Beitrag leisten das liefert
das Gesetz und zum Rettungsschirm ja wir
werden zum Thema Energiekosten Ausgleich
für Kliniken und Pflegeversorgung was
tun ja wir müssen bei der bei der
inflationsbremse im Gesundheitswesen
ansetzen und werden auf die Länder
zukommen und sie beim Wort nehmen dass
wir das gemeinsam schultern und ja auch
Strukturreform sind mit der
krankenhauskommission auf den Weg
gebracht werden hier eingebracht werden
und das wirklich 16 Jahre verfehlte
Politik nicht in 16 Monaten aufgelöst
sind was ist das für ein glaube das ist
einfach wirklich unredliche Opposition
und ich finde da haben die noch eine
Menge nachzuholen wir gehen hier
wirklich die Probleme an und sind für
ernstgemeinte Vorschläge gerne offen und
werden sie im parlamentarischen
Verfahren gerne gemeinsam beraten
der gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen vor
seiner Zeit im Parlament war er
medizinaldirektor und Oberarzt in der
ärztlichen Leitung des Rettungsdienst
Berlin für die Berliner Feuerwehren
nächster Redner Jörg Schneider AFD
Arzneimittel versorgen da geht es unter
anderem Grippe Impfstoffe sie sehen hier
einen erhöhten Bedarf und da sollten wir
doch vielleicht mal fragen wo kommt der
eigentlich her seit zweieinhalb Jahren
schüren sie Corona engst und das hört ja
nicht auf wird des Herrn Ministers eine
verunglückte Desinformationskampagne und
das verfängt viele Menschen vermeiden
bis heute soziale Kontakte verlassen die
eigene Wohnung nur mit einer Maske vor
dem Gesicht und das ist ein Problem denn
soziale Kontakte ohne Maske das sorgt
dafür dass das Immunsystem einer
gewissen Belastung ausgesetzt wird das
ist trainiert wird und dieses Training
fehlt vielen Menschen
dieses Training führt vielen Menschen
und
meine Partei hat darauf relativ früh
reagiert wir haben gefordert dass wir
zur Normalität zurückkehren das haben
sie abgelehnt sie wollen jetzt mehr
impfen einmal mehr lösen Sie also mit
erheblichen finanziellen Aufwand ein
Problem dass wir ohne ihre Politik
überhaupt nicht hätten meine Damen und
Herren
eine Aspekt ein Aspekt der
Arzneimittelversorgung sind
Lieferengpässe das hängt vor allen
Dingen mit den Produktionsstandorten
zusammen die liegen nämlich in Indien
und China China fährt gerade mit einer
irrensirokowit-politik die Lieferketten
vor die Wand und das wird sie in Zukunft
nicht besser die Inder haben zwar gerne
die 10 Milliarden Euro Entwicklungshilfe
angenommen die sie den hinterher
geworfen haben orientieren sich aber
mehr in Richtung Russland zuverlässige
Lieferanten sind das für mich nicht und
dabei haben sie in der großen Koalition
eigentlich ganz vernünftig angefangen im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass sie eine
Rückverlagerung der Produktion von
Arzneimitteln zu uns wünschen ich darf
Sie dafür loben weil das eine alte Idee
der AFD ist die sie da übernommen haben
und jetzt wäre doch die Gelegenheit
gewesen in diesem Gesetz mal endlich
ihren Worten Taten folgen zu lassen
Anreize zu setzen für diese
Rückverlagerung der Produktion und sie
sie machen genau das Gegenteil sie
ziehen die Schrauben an und mit den
Vorschlägen die sie dort gemacht haben
werden sie auch noch den letzten
arzneimittelproduzent nach Asien
vertreiben meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir haben hier in Deutschland
schon längst die Welt dümmste
Energiepolitik und das nächste Kapitel
ist jetzt noch die weltdümmste
arzneimittelpolitik
wir haben genau in diesem Zusammenhang
einige Vorschläge gemacht und wir wollen
doch in die gleiche Richtung also folgen
sie denen doch bitte sorgen wir
gemeinsam dafür dass der
arzneimittelproduktionsstandort
Deutschland bestärkt wird und sorgen wir
auch gemeinsam dafür dass die Menschen
hier in Deutschland sicher jederzeit mit
Arzneimittel versorgt werden folgen Sie
unseren Anträgen ich danke Ihnen
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Maximilian Mordhorst und er ist Mitglied
im Finanzausschuss
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es wurde angesprochen 17
Milliarden Euro Defizit und darüber
müssen wir reden ich glaube jeder der in
der Grundschule den Matheunterricht
besucht hat sollte wissen dass das
schwierige Entscheidungen erfordert mich
wundert vor allem dass vor diesem
Hintergrund die Unionsfraktion ihren
ersten Rede Slot dem Vertreter einer
Landesregierung in Deutschland gibt die
in den letzten Jahren die größte
nehmermentalität an den Tag gelegt hat
die wir erlebt haben die unter anderem
mit dafür verantwortlich sind dass wir
jetzt in dieser Situation sind lieber
Herr hollitschek sie haben sie haben
sich gewundert dass der
Bundesfinanzminister nicht dieses Gesetz
einbringt sie sind aber selbst hier und
reden ich habe mich schon gefragt warum
machen sie das eigentlich fünf Stunden
Anreise aus Bayern nachher geht es
wieder fünf Stunden zurück was sie
machen wollen haben sie überhaupt nicht
vorgestellt das kann doch nicht alles
nur für ein selfie mit Jens Spahn
gewesen sein stattdessen
stattdessen lesen Sie ein Wunschzettel
vor ich habe mal ein bisschen ich habe
mal ein bisschen mitgeschrieben Beiträge
soll niedrig bleiben der Bundeszuschuss
soll hoch beim Wohngeld sollen noch mehr
gemacht werden was wollen Sie denn
machen wir machen wir haben als Bund
eine schwierige finanzpolitische Lage
die Länder werden Überschüsse erzielen
das stimmt etwas in der
Verhältnismäßigkeit nicht ich würde mir
wünschen dass sie beim nächsten Mal wenn
sie hier vortragen ist ja schön wenn die
bundesratsbank nicht ganz leer ist aber
auch mal ein bisschen darüber berichten
was Bayern denn tun möchte um dieses
gemeinsame Problem zu lösen
ich will deswegen für die FDP-Fraktion
ganz klar sagen ich habe auch bei ihnen
vor allem in dieser Woche sehr genau
zugehört wir haben auf einer Seite die
Situation dass wir die Schuldenbremse
einhalten müssen weil wir sonst
finanzpolitische Probleme bekommen die
Zinskosten werden schon nächstes Jahr
auf 30 Milliarden Euro steigen und wer
nicht wie die Linke ein
Subventionsprogramm für Banken und
Investmentfonds machen will der muss
wenig Schulden machen auf der anderen
Seite haben wir extreme
Herausforderungen zu bewältigen und dann
sehe ich von der Unionsfraktion die
ganze Woche nur neue Ausgaben Vorschläge
es hat nicht mal ein Jahr gedauert dass
sie ohne jegliche
Finanzierungsvorschläge immer wieder
neue Ideen haben wo man mehr Geld
ausgeben könnte wo man weniger Geld
einnehmen könnte wir haben das bei allen
möglichen Debatten erlebt ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir in ihnen auch als
Oppositionsfraktion eine stärkere
Unterstützerin beim Bereich
finanzpolitische Solidarität bei
möglichst Schuldenbremsen und
ausgeglichenen Haushalten bekommen das
wäre etwas wovon wir in Deutschland
profitieren können und nicht diese immer
größer und länger werdenden Wunschzettel
in Deutschland wir werden jetzt
unangenehme Entscheidungen treffen Karl
Lauterbach hat es vorgestellt es wurde
dann gleich nach seiner Rede wieder
abgeräumt hat um möglichst wenig Polemik
gebeten aber werden unangenehme
Entscheidungen treffen das muss man den
Menschen auch mal ehrlich sagen ich bin
der Überzeugung wir müssen diesen Weg
den wir jetzt beschritten haben
weitergehen und notwendige Maßnahmen als
ampelregierung auch dann treffen wenn
Sie kurzfristig unpopulär sind ich würde
mir wünschen dass möglichst viele aus
der Opposition diesen Mut auch haben und
dass wir gemeinsam dafür einstehen
einerseits finanzpolitische Solidarität
zu gewährleisten aber andererseits auch
die Herausforderungen zu bewältigen die
jetzt vor uns stehen ohne in Populismus
zu verfallen vielen Dank
sagt Maximilian Mordhorst aus der
FDP-Fraktion und wir sind bei der
drittletzten Rednerin in dieser Debatte
angekommen die Jana Stöcker wird das
sein aus der Unionsfraktion und sie ist
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren eines ist klar die
Finanzen der gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
werden im kommenden Jahr ein enormes
Defizit aufweisen nicht leicht aber wie
hoch der Fehlbetrag nun tatsächlich sein
wird die 17 Milliarden Euro das zeichnet
sich jetzt schon ab sind werden nicht
ausreichend und die Folgejahre sehen
nicht besser aus daher ist es umso
wichtiger strukturelle und vor allem
nachhaltige Reformschritte zu gehen und
zwar jetzt ankündigen haben wir genug
gehabt
Herr Minister was Sie bei diesem
Gesetzentwurf machen ist kreativlos mit
heißer Nadel gestrickt und rein auf
kurzfristigen Ertrag angelegt sie drehen
allein an den Stellschrauben
rücklageneinnahmen und Ausgaben aller
beteiligten Akteure der hessische
Ministerpräsident Boris rein formulierte
kürzlich zu recht schnelles Geld durch
schnelle Schnitte sämtliche Bereiche
unseres Gesundheitswesens werden bis zur
Schmerzgrenze belastet Herr Minister
wird dem vorliegenden Entwurf schafft
ein einmaliger zusätzlicher
Bundeszuschuss wie sie in vorschlagen
verknüpft mit einem bundesdarlehen
stellt sicher keinen nachhaltigen
Finanzierungsbeitrag zur Sicherung der
GKV-Finanzierung da diese Ampel hat
offensichtlich nicht mal die Kraft die
eigenen Vorhaben umzusetzen wir fordern
Sie daher auf den vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf zu überarbeiten und
unser Gesundheitswesen nicht weiter zu
belasten der vorgelegte Entwurf löst
nicht die Probleme der
Krankenversicherung erschafft neue und
ist daher der falsche Weg
Diana Stöcker aus der Unionsfraktion und
ihr folgt jetzt in dieser ersten
Beratung eines Gesetzentwurfs des der
Bundesregierung mit deren mit dessen
Hilfe wenn es der Meinung Gesetz ist die
Finanzlage der Krankenkassen
stabilisiert und verbessert werden soll
Heike Behrens gesundheitspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung hat
sich in pandemiezeiten als stabiler
Faktor erwiesen und trotzdem hat diese
größte Gesundheitskrise der
Nachkriegszeit Spuren hinterlassen
überfälliger Reformen wurden hint
angestellt finanzielle Polster
aufgebraucht entschiedene Maßnahmen sind
jetzt notwendig um die gute und
solidarische Gesundheitsversorgung in
unserem Land für alle zu sichern
in Krisenzeiten
gilt es die Reihen zu schließen und
zusammen zu stehen da ist es mehr als
befremdlich wenn die Fraktion die in den
letzten zehn Jahren das
Gesundheitsministerium geführt die
Gesundheitsminister gestellt und ganz
wesentlich zu der aktuellen
kostendynamik beigetragen hat jetzt mit
dem Finger auf die ampelregierung zeigt
sie als cdu/csu waren es nur mal ein
Beispiel die trotz offensichtlicher
jahrelanger Ausgaben Zuwächse bei
patentierten Arzneimitteln die Reformen
im amnock-verfahren auf die lange Bank
geschoben haben und das obwohl allen
Kennern der Reformbedarf längst klar war
das gehen wir jetzt an
der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf bietet
eine gute Grundlage um die dringend
notwendige zeitnah Stabilisierung der
kassenfinanzen zu gewährleisten aber uns
allen ist klar dass damit noch keine
nachhaltige Konsolidierung erreicht wird
um unser Gesundheitssystem auf einem
guten Qualitätsniveau funktions- und
leistungsfähig zu halten ist es
notwendig Effizienzreserven zu heben und
die überfälligen Strukturreformen auf
den Weg zu bringen das haben wir uns als
Ampelkoalition nicht nur vorgenommen
sondern das packen wir an
im ersten Schritt mit den nun zu
diskutierenden Maßnahmen zur
kurzfristigen Kostendämpfung aber eben
im zweiten Schritt mit den langfristig
wirksamen Strukturmaßnahmen die bis Ende
Mai nächsten Jahres vorliegen werden und
selbstverständlich werden wir dafür
sorgen dass Krankenhäuser Gesundheits-
und Pflegeeinrichtungen nicht von den
aktuellen Preissteigerungen überfordert
werden auch daran arbeitet die Regierung
gerade mit Hochdruck und Minister Karl
Lauterbach hat zugesagt in Kürze dazu
einen konkreten Vorschlag vorzulegen ja
ich habe es vorhin bereits gesagt in
Krisenzeiten heißt es zusammen zu stehen
jede und jeder muss einen Beitrag dazu
leisten damit die Krise nicht zum
Kollaps wird
dass die Kritik an diesen Gesetzentwurf
nun aus allen unterschiedlichen
Richtungen kommt kann ich verstehen es
zeigt aber auch dass hier eben alle ein
Stück weit in die Verantwortung genommen
werden
und da muss ich einfach doch noch mal
auch auf das eingehen was der
Gesundheitsminister aus Bayern vorhin
hier gesagt hat denn es reicht nicht
wenn die CDU und CSU
Ministerpräsidenten oder
Gesundheitsminister hier immer nur mit
dem Finger auf dem Bund zeigen und das
Geld vom Bund einfordern Jana Stamm hat
es vorhin am Thema Krankenhäuser auf den
Punkt gebracht
jahrelang haben hier die Bundesländer
eben die Investitionsfinanzierung nicht
ausreichend gemacht und haben damit
Mittel aus dem Solidarsystem
herausgesaugt und wir haben heute die
Situation dass in vielen Bereichen eben
die Krankenhäuser tatsächlich marode
sind und dringend auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind und das ist im Wesentlichen die
Verantwortung die auf Länderseite
wahrgenommen werden muss
und ich sage Ihnen auch wir werden sie
im nächsten Jahr stellen denn wenn es
jetzt um die notwendigen
Strukturreformen geht dann werden wir
auch darüber reden müssen ob nicht die
Arzneimittel bei der Mehrwertsteuer
entlastet werden müssen es ist doch
nicht nachvollziehbar das
tierarztneimittel den mit niedrigen
Mehrwertsteuersatz belastet werden aber
die human Arzneimittel mit dem Vollen
meierwald-steuersatz und dann
diskutieren wir mal ob die Länder
bereits sind ihre Verantwortung
wahrzunehmen
und ob in diesem Gesetzentwurf ob der
ausreichend ob es darin ausreichend
gerecht zugeht oder ob das eine oder
andere vielleicht noch geändert werden
müssen das werden wir sehr sorgfältig im
Rahmen des nun beginnenden
parlamentarischen Verfahrens prüfen und
diskutieren für meine Fraktion
jedenfalls kann ich schon jetzt sagen
dass wir durchaus noch Redebedarf haben
wie wir auch das auf den Weg bringen
können was wir ganz konkret im
Koalitionsvertrag miteinander vereinbart
fahren lassen Sie uns heute und im
weiteren parlamentarischen Verfahren
intensiv und respektvoll diskutieren
vielen Dank
Heike Behrens war dass sie
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion war heute morgen um Viertel
von neun schon bei uns im Interview
gemeinsam mit seppen Müller aus der
Unionsfraktion das können sie nachgucken
über unsere Social Media Kanäle auch auf
der Homepage und über kurz oder lang
sicherlich auch auf unserem
Youtube-Kanal wir sind beim letzten
Redner dieser Debatte das ist Georg
kippels aus der Unionsfraktion
Inhalt die Aufmerksamkeit auf einen ganz
speziellen Punkt zu der lenken
gesundheit ist ein hohes Gut und
Gesundheit ist ein teures Gut im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes jeden Tag
investieren wir eine Milliarde Euro in
unser Gesundheitssystem die finanziellen
Herausforderungen sind jetzt ausführlich
dargestellt worden und ich wende mich
einer Bemerkung von Minister Lauterbach
zu der davon gesprochen hat dass wir
innovationsbereit bleiben wollen und
keine Leistungskürzungen vornehmen
wollen machen wir die Probe aufs Exempel
anhand dieses Gesetzes und wenn wir uns
den seltenen Krankheiten zu die dort
mehr am Rande aber von prominenter
Bedeutung erwähnt sind was sind seltene
Krankheiten vier Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland leben mit einer solchen
Erkrankung aber sind insgesamt ca 8.000
verschiedene Krankheitsbilder derzeit
gibt es 138 Medikamente die man in
diesem Bereich nach einer 20 Jahre alten
EU-Verordnung offen Drax eine spezielle
zulassungsmethode ist angewendet worden
bei schweren und tödlich verlaufenden
Erkrankungen und ohne entsprechende
vergleichstherapien werden diese
Medikamente von der EMA der europäischen
medikamentenagentur zugelassen und
können dann in die Therapie kommen was
ist tatsächlich das verbreitungsbild
mehr als fünf Menschen dürfen von 10.000
Menschen dürfen nicht an dieser
Krankheit leiden ohne dass es dann zum
Ausfall aus dieser Kategorisierung
kommen diese Medikamente sind äußerst
aufwendig und vor allen Dingen sehr
teuer zu entwickeln weil die
Patientengruppen sehr klein sind und die
Möglichkeiten für die Durchführung von
Studien infolgedessen sehr erschwert
sind was sagt das GKV
finanzierungsstabilisierungsgesetz zu
diesem Themenbereich es ist eigentlich
eine vielleicht zunächst mal belanglose
Regelungen nämlich die Tatsache dass
Umsatzschwelle in der diese Medikamente
vergütet werden und eingeordnet werden
von jährlich 50 auf 20 Millionen
reduziert werden klingt zunächst mal
nicht besonders
von besonderer Tragweite hat aber auf
die Anwendung und vor allen Dingen die
forschungsfähigkeit für diese
Medikamente eine enorme Tragweite denn
sinkt man und überschreibt man diese
Umsatzschwelle ist das Medikament nach
der normalen Regelung der
zusatznutzenbewertung des amnock
Arzneimittel neuordnungsgesetzes aus dem
Jahre 2011 einer Zulassung zu
unterziehen ein sehr komplexes Verfahren
und vor allen Dingen für diese
Medikamente deshalb so problematisch
weil häufig zu diesem Zeitpunkt die
notwendigen Studien der Studie der
Studienphase 3 mit entsprechenden Daten
nicht vorliegen und die ganz konkrete
Besorgnis besteht dass auf diese Art und
Weise die Medikamente entweder vom Markt
genommen werden oder aber erst gar nicht
in die Anwendung kommen zusätzlich gibt
es dann noch Regelungen die sich im
Hinblick auf die Kombinationstherapien
mit einem zwangsabschlag beschäftigen
die Vorgaben für den Zusatznutzen sind
geregelt und bei verwürfen durch
unwirtschaftliche Packungsgrößen gibt es
auch Abschläge insgesamt die gesamte
Maßnahme führt dazu dass eine wirklich
gute Entwicklung in Deutschland zu
Entwicklung der Orphan Drugs gestoppt
wird möglicherweise ein Rückfall in die
Zeit vor das anglog erfolgt und damit
haben wir eine Leistungskürzung durch
die Hintertüre und damit auch eine
Schädigung der Innovationsfähigkeit der
deutschen Pharmaindustrie
und wie wichtig gerade kleine Schritte
erste Schritte sind haben wir bei
biontech erlebt deshalb entweder ist
diese Regelung für die seltenen
Krankheiten im Gesetz schlicht und
ergreifend ein Systemfehler das wäre ein
Skandal wäre es beabsichtigt wäre es
noch ein viel größerer Skandal deshalb
Herr Minister nehmen Sie diese Regelung
für die offenprax raus und macht sie
Politik für Menschen mit seltenen
Erkrankungen vielen Dank
georg kippels hat sich da bedankt aber
der letzte Redner in dieser Debatte und
jetzt gibt es ein paar Formalia denn in
dieser Debatte gibt es ja nicht nur den
Gesetzentwurf aus dem
Gesundheitsministerium sondern es liegen
auch mehrere Anträge vor aus den Reihen
von AFD und Linksfraktion die werden
jetzt überwiegend überwiesen werden
in die
Fachausschüsse also Gesundheitsausschuss
mal ganz weit vorne und wir gucken mal
ganz kurz rein wie die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel war's das
hier gestaltet und natürlich wird in dem
federführend Gesundheitsausschuss dann
natürlich auch der
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung weiter
beraten werden bevor er hier wieder
in den Bundestag kommt und jetzt habe
ich Unternehmen gerade gehört es ist
alles schon geleistet die Überweisungen
die fällig waren haben schon
stattgefunden sie sehen eine gewisse
Rotation hier im Parlament weil die
Fachpolitiker in Sachen Gesundheit
Krankenkassen etc und jetzt den Saal
verlassen der nächste Tagesordnungspunkt
ist ein Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
energiepolitische Perspektive für Bürger
und Unternehmen so ist es überschrieben
es geht darum Bürgern und Unternehmen
eine
Perspektive zu geben für die kommenden
Monate in Sachen Preissteigerungen
zwei stromgas aber auch bei anderen
Verbraucherpreisen die Preise sollen
unter Kontrolle gebracht werden eine
Insolvenzwelle soll verhindert werden so
ist das Ansinnen der Unionsfraktion und
deswegen sind sie auch ganz unzufrieden
mit dem Entlastungspaket 3 mehr dazu von
Mario Czaja aus der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren lieber und es
Wirtschaftsminister es ist glaube ich
die
vierte Debatte in dieser Woche die wir
zum Thema Energiekrise führen
es ist ja auch der einzige konstruktive
und intensive Antrag der heute im
Parlament in dieser Woche vorhanden ist
und die Lage
die Lage ist ausgesprochen kritisch
viele
viele Prominente Fälle
sie brauchen jetzt nicht dazwischen
rufen sondern schauen sich einfach die
Fälle an die wir derzeitig im Land haben
dann werden Sie sehen dass die Lage
dramatisch ist und sie auf diese Lage
nicht reagieren derzeit ist
toilettenpapierhersteller Hakle hat
wegen hohe Energie- und Materialkosten
Insolvenz angemeldet
Metallgießerei mit drei Standorten 160
Mitarbeitern in Brandenburg wegen fast
dreifach gestiegener Stromkosten
Insolvenz angemeldet Bäckerei jüngsten
Ostfriesland 99 Jahre da nächstes
jahrhundertjähriges Jubiläum so stark
steigende Energiekosten dass sie vor der
Insolvenz stehen jedes dritte
Unternehmen im industriellen Mittelstand
sieht den gestiegenen Energie- und
Rohstoffpreisen so kritisch gegenüber
dass die eigene Existenz in Frage steht
fast jedes zehnte Unternehmen in
Deutschland hat bereits die Produktion
gedrosselt oder ganz eingestellt viele
Unternehmen haben Angst dass wir
Unternehmen bei draufgeht dass ihr
Lebenswerk in Frage gestellt wird dass
es keine Jobs mehr gibt dass die
Familien in Gefahr sind das ist eine
dramatische Situation und auf diese
Situation reagiert diese Bundesregierung
in keiner anständigen Art und Weise
und
jetzt werden wir höchstwahrscheinlich
höchstwahrscheinlich von einzelnen
wieder die Aussagen bekommen ja die
Ursachen und 16 Jahre dieser Evergreen
den wir hier immer und immer wieder
hören
die Wahrheit ist eben nur die Wahrheit
ist eben nur die Ursache für die
jetzigen Probleme sind die letzten 16
Wochen nicht die letzten 16 Jahre
die hätte die Bundesregierung hätte die
Bundesregierung Ideologie frei die Dinge
angepackt die wir anpacken wollten
nämlich das Angebot zu erhöhen dann
werden die Probleme heute nicht so groß
wie sie sind hätte die Bundesregierung
den energiepreisdeckel gemacht die wir
Ihnen vorgeschlagen haben vorher schon
vor 16 Wochen wer die Lage heute nicht
so dramatisch hätte man die wirklich
Betroffenen entlastet und nicht mit der
Gießkanne an allen Ecken und Endungen
Veränderungen herbeizuführen dann würden
die Rentner auch jetzt zum ersten
zehnten ihre 300 Euro Energiewelt
bekommen das ist aber nicht der Fall
unsere Vorschläge lagen auf dem Tisch
und
und es liegt doch auf der Hand dass sie
jetzt so dazwischen rufen weil aus ihren
eigenen Reihen weil aus ihren eigenen
Reihen die genau die gleichen Vorschläge
immer wieder kommen nur nicht hier im
Parlament
spd-arbeitnehmerflüge fordert
gaspreisdeckel staatlichen
gaspreisdeckel soll stattfinden liest
man auch übrigens in weiten Teilen der
SPD wir hören das Christian Lindner sagt
dass wir beim Angebot die Kernkraftwerke
aufstocken müssen und dass wir bei den
drei Kernkraftwerken bleiben müssen wir
hören von ein Habeck dass er sagt bei
der Biomasse sollten wir endlich was tun
die niedersächsischen Bauern sagen dass
wenn Sie Ihre bestehenden Biogasanlagen
vollständig ausnutzen könnten die jetzt
schon bestehenden können Sie fünf
Prozent des russischen Gases ersetzen
sie macht können es aber nicht machen
weil die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen
von ihnen derzeitig dafür nicht
geschaffen werden
und es fällt wirklich schwer aber
unsererseits gilt weiterhin die
ausgestreckte Hand wir erreichten die
Hand für eine konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit und für die Lösung dieser
Probleme unsere Vorschläge liegen seit
Wochen Tag und Wochen auf dem Tisch und
wir sagen klar alles für eine sichere
Energieversorgung mobilisieren wenn es
wenn das Angebot knapp ist steigt der
Preis einfache Regel erstes Semester
Habeck bei Betriebswirtschaftslehre
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen
biogasdeckel wieder anheben auch die
Änderungen im Baugesetzbuch ist dafür
notwendig um das bei der biogasse hinzu
Biomasse hinzubekommen deswegen der
erste Punkt bleibt das Angebot
das zweite Thema ist weiterhin die
Bürger zu entlasten und für eine
bezahlbare Grundversorgung zu sorgen
dafür haben wir den preisdeckel
vorgeschlagen und zwar auf einem Niveau
von 75% haben wir ihn diskutiert um auch
die Anreize dahingehend zu haben zu
sparen und gleichzeitig eben auch
Sicherheit für alle Einkommen zu
gewährleisten und das dritte ist die
Unternehmen anständig zu unterstützen
das tun sie nicht stand 7.9 haben 586
Unternehmen
3208 Anträge gestellt um aus ihrem Fond
Mittel zu bekommen
3.200 und 8 Anträge davon sind 24 24
sind davon positiv beschieden worden das
ist lächerlich und keine Unterstützung
sowie der Mittelstand überhaupt
sie haben ja am Beginn dieser Woche ein
fußballbild bedient um die Debatte zu
beschreiben
ich bin manchmal im Stadion
und wenn ich da so auf die Mannschaft
runter schaue dann sind die Fans relativ
leidensfähig die Murren nicht immer
aber wenn sie merken dass die Mannschaft
da unten nur gegeneinander agiert und
nicht gemeinsam aufs Tor geht und nicht
die wesentlichen Dinge im Auge hat und
das ist das was wir derzeitig bei der
Bundesregierung erleben dann müssen Sie
sich nicht wundern dass es dafür kein
Applaus mehr gibt sondern dass es dafür
erhebliche Kritik gibt sie sind mit
dafür verantwortlich dass wir ein
solches Chaos und ein solches
gegeneinander in dieser Regierung
erleben wir haben den Gegenvorschlag auf
den Tisch gelegt folgt sie diesen
Mario Czaja für die cdu/csu-fraktion er
ist ja auch Generalsekretär der CDU und
ich würde jetzt mal interessieren welche
Stadion er gemeint hat denn die
Beschreibung die er abgeliefert hat von
der Mannschaft die ja da vermeintlich
sieht kann auf Union Berlin ja
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig passen
passiv sind die nun wirklich nicht
Timon gremmels ist der nächste Redner
und er kommt aus der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich glaube jeder von
uns kann Beispiele aus seinen Wahlkreis
nennen wie die Situation vor Ort ist ich
war in den letzten Wochen unter anderem
bei einem Müller einer der 150 Malereien
die noch selber Mehl malen und nicht
Industriekonzern untergeordnet sind der
hat mir gesagt noch Zeit der 5 Cent
Strompreis die Kilowattstunde sein
Mühlgraben ist ausgetrocknet und das
Angebot für den nächsten ersten weil da
läuft seinen Strompreis ist ein
Stromvertrag aus sind 70 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde das schafft er nicht und
er sagt dann kann er eben hier kein Mehl
mehr mahlen und was das dann in Folge
für Auswirkungen hätte auch auf die
Nahrungsmittelpreise auf die
Nahrungsmittel Verfügbarkeit das kann
sich jeder vorstellen und ich hatte auch
das Gespräch mit einer Bäckerei in
meinem Wahlkreis die vor einem Jahr in
einen neuen Ofen investiert haben und
gesagt haben jetzt super das wird jetzt
alles effizienter werden die das noch
und jetzt aber auch vor den großen
Problemen der steigenden Energiepreise
stehen diese Menschen wenden sich an uns
und die Menschen sagen wir brauchen
Unterstützung und ich kann sagen ja
diese Koalition liefert diese Koalition
handelt wir unterstützen hier gilt das
Wort unseres Kanzlers oder Scholz keiner
wird alleine gelassen you never walk
alone meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren und ganz konkret ist das was ihr
einfach mal auch von dieser
Bundesregierung auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist für die große
exportorientierte Industrie nämlich das
kostendämpfungsprogramm Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm jetzt auch angekündigt
dass das um eine mittelstandsschiene für
Kleid und mittlere Unternehmen erweitert
werden soll das ist genau das richtige
Signal dass es jetzt auch Programme gibt
die für den Mittelstand die für das
Handwerk orientiert sind und deswegen
ist es gut dass angekündigte wurde es
ist gut dass das auch wenn ich den
Minister richtig verstanden habe
rückwirkend erfolgen soll per
Abschlagszahlung erfolgen soll als
Zuschuss erfolgen soll das hilft konkret
das ist konkretes Handeln meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
was mir dann allerdings schon schwerer
fällt nachzuvollziehen ist wenn ich dann
höre dass es jetzt administrative
Probleme gibt weil die Schnittstellen
nicht so ganz da sind weil diese
Computerprogramme neu programmiert
werden soll weil es Probleme gibt
welches Instrument der Auszahlung man
wählen soll ich habe so ein bisschen das
Gefühl gehabt ich käme mir vor wie vor
zwei Jahren in der corona-pandemie war
wieder all diese Probleme hatten ich
glaube wir müssen dringend mal gucken
dass wir Strukturen schaffen die auch
nachhaltig wirken und mein Appell auch
an die Union die das heute hier zum
Thema macht sie sollten auch mal gucken
was in ihren eigenen Ländern ist wenn
ich höre dass sich der einige Länder
weigern sozusagen bei der Frage der
Auszahlung ihrer Infrastruktur zur
Verfügung zu stellen weil die Länder
noch in der Abwicklung der
corona-programme beschäftigt sind den
Schlussabrechnung kann das auch nicht
sein wir sind in einer Situation einer
nationalen größten Herausforderung seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hier darf es nicht
sein dass Bund und Länder gegeneinander
Politik betreiben sondern hier müssen
wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass die
Zahlungen schnell ausgeführt werden
meine Damen und Herren und da erwarten
wir dass die Länder auch ihren Beitrag
leisten und dass sie ihre Möglichkeiten
wie bei der corona-pandemie konstruktiv
zur Verfügung stellen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren deswegen ist
es gut dass wir hier an dieser Stelle
handeln und wir machen ja noch mehr die
großartige Erfindung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes die damals Olaf
Scholz als Arbeits- und Sozialminister
auf den Weg gebracht hat die uns schon
geholfen hat in der corona-pandemie auch
die wird jetzt weiter genutzt auch das
ist etwas was Menschen in einer
schwierigen Situation Sicherheit gibt
und das ist auch gut meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und wir haben
noch was gemacht wir haben jetzt eine
energiepreisbremse auf den Weg gebracht
und wo wir sagen die zufallsgewinne die
jetzt entstehen die müssen abgeschöpft
werden es ist eine Frage der Solidarität
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und damit ist auch die rechte Seite in
diesem Hause versteht ist eine Frage des
Patriotismus ist es jetzt nicht sein
kann dass die unter Firmen jetzt schon
wieder gucken dass sie Auswege und
Schlupflöcher suchen um das nicht zahlen
zu müssen mein Appell heute ist hier an
dieser Stelle auch die Unternehmen auch
die Industrie die jetzt dort auch die
Energiewirtschaft die an dieser Stelle
richtige Gewinne macht muss sich
solidarisch muss sich patriotisch
Verhalten und nicht Auswege suchen
sondern das Geld zahlen was wir brauchen
um die Menschen zu entlasten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das muss an
dieser Stelle auch mal deutlich gesagt
werden das muss deutlich gesagt werden
ja und wir müssen auch weitere Dinge tun
schneller als wir es vorhatten das
Marktdesign das strohmarktdesign zu
überarbeiten aber meine Damen und Herren
das ist eine Operation am offenen Herz
das kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
bei ebenso schnell durchpeitschen das
braucht das ist europäisch verletzt wenn
wir hier Fehler machen dann droht eine
große Katastrophe und ich will es an
dieser Stelle sagen deswegen müssen wir
hier gemein ich ja ich höre ja immer
ihre klugen Vorschläge hier vorne es ist
aber in der Tat so dass wir da ganz gut
zusammen rangehen müssen und der Scheuer
wenn Sie hier eben gerade sagen was man
alles hätte tun müssen ich sage Ihnen
jetzt mal zwei Dinge die hätten getan
werden müssen
denn Herr Seehofer und dann später Herr
Söder als Ministerpräsident von Bayern
nicht sozusagen den südlichen verhindert
hätten gegen jede Leitung gekämpft
hätten wenn sie nicht 10h eingeführt
hätten dann wären wir heute deutlich
weiter denn hätte insbesondere Bayern
diese Probleme nicht vor den wir heute
stehen deswegen ducken sie sich nicht
aus der Verantwortung ich mache mir
jetzt es nicht so leicht und rekoriere
auf die 16 Jahre das ja das ist jetzt ja
ein Jahr her man sollte nein das mache
ich nicht aber Herr Söder ist heute noch
in der Verantwortung deswegen sage ich
heute muss er liefern auch heute muss er
endlich 10 her komplett abschaffen auch
jetzt muss er seinen Widerstand gegen
Stromtrassen aufgeben das hat nicht für
die letzten Jahren zu tun die letzten 16
Jahre das hat mit der Gegenwart zu tun
jetzt muss gehandelt werden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
und ich sage ihnen war ja eine spannende
Rede sie machen hier in der in der
Kernzeit so eine Debatte auf und gehen
gar nicht darauf ein dass wir heute
morgen um sieben eine Anhörung hatten im
energieausschuss zum ensig 3.0
energiesicherungsgesetz 3.0 wo wir
intensiv diskutieren wie wir jetzt
kurzfristig und schnell die Potenziale
heben das ist nein nicht seit nein wir
gucken beim zum Beispiel beim N6 3.0
Netze da gibt es effizienzmodule da gibt
es effizienzmöglichkeiten bei der
Windkraft beim Gas bei der Photovoltaik
da werden wir der nächsten Woche hier
etwas auf den Weg bringen was sofort ja
nächste Woche ist die dritte Lesung was
ganz schnell hilft meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren und nochmals wenn Sie
jetzt hier reinschreien das Versagen
liegt doch bei ihnen sie haben die
letzten sie haben doch immer gegen
Windkraft gekämpft und sie kämpfen doch
auch heute noch gegen Windkraftanlagen
und da gucken wir mal ihre Bilanz an
gucken wir mal ihre Bilanz an da wo sie
mit regieren ich sage Ihnen eins ich war
letzte Woche bei der IHK mittelstandsaus
die waren bei mir in Kassel und wir
haben auch über Energiepolitik
diskutiert da ging es gar nicht in
erster Linie und Förderprogramme da ging
es darum dass die Bürokratie das
Genehmigungsverfahren so ellenlang
dauern da hat ein Unternehmen gesagt sie
könnten schon heute auf Fotovoltaik
setzen wenn dort die Verfahren länger
gedauert werden und ich sage eins gleich
bei Windkraft da wo sie regieren Hessen
38,2 Monate Planungszeit für ein
Windkraftanlage das muss geändert werden
wir müssen schneller werden müssen
schneller erneuerbare Energien aufs
Tableau bringen das ist die Antwort aus
der Krise das hilft auch den
Bäckermeister vor Ort erneuerbare
Energien sind auf lange Sicht der
kostensenker in diesem Sinne alles Gute
zum Glück auf
so und dann haben wir die erwarteten
Emotionen in dieser Debatte in der es um
einen Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion geht
die energiepolitische Perspektiven für
Bürgerinnen und Unternehmen fordert
Enrico Comlink ist jetzt am Pool für die
afd-fraktion
die wirtschaftliche Lage der Unternehmen
spezielle Mittelschule mittelständischen
Unternehmen als dramatisch zu bezeichnen
ist aus meiner Sicht schon fast ein
Euphemismus in meiner Heimatstadt
Neubrandenburg schließen sich
verzweifelte Unternehmer zusammen und
sie gehen auf die Straße der erste
unternehmeraufstand letzter Woche
folgten fast 3000 Menschen und ich sage
Ihnen das ist erst der Anfang die
Menschen die Unternehmer sie wehren sich
gegen eine Politik der Ideologen der
ökologieisten unter ahnungslosen und das
ist gut so meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kollegen von der Union in einem
gebe ich Ihnen und Ihrem Antrag recht
Ursache für die flächendeckende
Existenzbedrohung sind natürlich keine
unternehmerischen Entscheidung aber sehr
wohl politische politische
Entscheidungen Herr Czaja die sie und
sie meine Damen und Herren Kollegen von
der Union allen voran zu vertreten haben
die heute explodierenden Energiepreise
sind doch nur die seismischen
Erschütterungen die die Welle zum
Tsunami machen ihre Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel und ihr Wirtschaftsminister
Altmaier haben dieses Land energetisch
lautverband an die Wand gefahren
natürlich natürlich ist es auch der
gastkrieg auch der das Krieg ist schuld
aber auch wessen Mist ist der denn
bitteschön gewachsen wenn sie enttrauter
Eintracht mit der ampelregierung den
größten Rohstofflieferanten der Welt
sanktionieren das kann man ja machen
dann müssen sie aber mit den
entsprechenden Reaktionen rechnen sie
haben mit dem Schicksal der deutschen
gepokert ohne Blatt und offen ein
wirklich mieser love
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren jetzt
ist Holland oder besser Deutschland in
Not und sie kommen mit einem Antrag
voller
planwirtschaftlicher Lösungen staatlich
festgelegte Preise für staatlichung von
gasspeichern es ist im Grunde ein
Gruselkabinett Anforderungen die sie
hier stellen liebe Kollegen von der
Union ich verstehe ihren Ansatz den Sie
mit diesem Antrag verfolgen aber dieses
ausschließliche Herumdoktern an
Symptomen verspricht doch keine
energiepolitische Perspektive das
erreichen Sie nur durch Freiheit durch
Marktwirtschaft
Staatswirtschaft war noch nie die Lösung
Staatswirtschaft ist immer das Problem
verlassen sie verlassen sie den Weg
dieser entsetzlichen
sozialökologischen Transformationen den
Weg zu einer staatlich kontrollierten
Kreislaufwirtschaft denn er führt zu den
ins Industrialisierung zu Massenarmut
und zu Unfreiheit
sie drücken sich mit ihrem Antrag um das
eigentliche Problem das ist nämlich die
Energiewende
verabschieden sie sich endlich von
diesem Monstrum nur dann schaffen sie
auch eine wirkliche echte Perspektive
für Bürger und Unternehmen so aber so
aber liebe Union können wir ihrem Antrag
nicht zustimmen dieser Krieg diese
Energiekrise zeigen einmal mehr
Deutschland kann nur als starkes Land
bestehen wenn es eine Zukunft im Konzert
der Nationen haben will und deshalb
meine Damen und Herren gerade da oben
vielleicht auf der Tribüne aber auch
meine Damen und Herren Kollegen der
Union lassen Sie uns gemeinsam diesen
kamikazeflug der Bundesregierung stoppen
demonstrieren Sie mit uns am 8 Oktober
hier in Berlin gegen diese Politik
beenden wir diesen in Energiewende
Irrsinn finden wir zurück zu
Marktwirtschaft und Freiheit nicht nur
die Menschen in unserem Land auch der
Mittelstand wird es Ihnen danken vielen
Dank
Enrico coming aus der afd-fraktion
spricht von einem Gaskrieg und schafft
es auch in seiner Rede die Ursachen für
die aktuelle Lage komplett auszublenden
nämlich den Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine Dieter janitschek ist der
nächste rednerwirtschaftspolitischer
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Scharia die
wirtschaftliche Situation für viele
Betriebe ist besorgniserregend in
Deutschland für manche geht es an die
Existenz wir haben steigende
Energiekosten durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg allein die
Ersatzbeschaffung für russisches Gas in
diesem Jahr kostet uns um die 60
Milliarden Euro im nächsten Jahrhundert
Milliarden volkswirtschaftlich sind das
gigantische Verluste wir erleben die
Unterbrechung der internationalen
Lieferketten auch durch Entscheidungen
in China die nur kobit-politik dort die
Zins wenn sie der Zentralbanken belastet
natürlich auch Unternehmen zum Beispiel
im Bausektor in der Immobilienwirtschaft
dort haben wir einen deutlichen downturn
jetzt auch zu erwarten und auch die in
der Sache berechtigten höhere
Lohnforderungen sind natürlich aufgrund
von Inflationen für viele Unternehmen
erstmal eine Belastung
diese Probleme betreffen aber zurzeit
nicht uns regulär sie betreffen alle
europäischen Länder Glashersteller in
Frankreich Stahlwerke in Spanien
düngemittelfabriken in Polen viele
Branchen stehen vor großen
Herausforderungen und daher brauchen wir
auch europäische Lösungen der
unionsantrag nennt nicht mit einem Wort
Europa und das zeigt wie beschränkt sie
hier wieder agieren das war doch schon
in der Vergangenheit das Problem
wir brauchen eine europäisch abgestimmte
koordinierte Energiepolitik
Frankreich als Beispiel leidet zurzeit
unter den extrem hohen Strompreisen weil
sich dieses Land völlig abhängig gemacht
hat von der Atomkraft und deswegen
mussten wir diesen Sommer diesen Herbst
aushelfen um Frankreich zu stabilisieren
Deutschland hat sich in der
Vergangenheit von Vorgängerregierungen
abhängig gemacht in einer Art und Weise
von russischen Gas was uns heute in
diese Bredouille in diese schwierige
Situation gebracht hat das heißt
undurchdachte Energiepolitik der
Vergangenheit ist eine Folge des
Desasters heute und wir müssen damit
umgehen und das gehört auch zu
Ehrlichkeit hätten sie uns nicht in die
Abhängigkeit von solchen Autokraten
geführt würden wir heute anders dastehen
nun ist es ja so
wenn sie sagen dass wir mit zu wenig
Dynamik handeln würden
dass es wirklich eine Forderung einer
Feststellung die lachhaft ist es gab
kein Wirtschaftsministerium in den
letzten Jahrzehnten das so dynamisch auf
eine Krise reagiert hat wie dieses
Wirtschaftsministerium und der Robert
Habeck
wir haben bei Regierungsübernahme leere
Gasspeicher über Normen jetzt haben wir
volle Gasspeicher in schwierigster Lage
seitdem können wir übrigens auch Preise
wieder drücken weil wir in der Lage sind
dass wir nicht mehr zu jedem Preis
einkaufen müssen wir müssen die
Einkaufspolitik der Europäischen Union
beim Thema Gas bündeln natürlich müssen
wir auch den Unternehmen helfen deswegen
steht jetzt ganz konkret in den
Verhandlungen im Kabinett im Parlament
an dass wir ein
energiekostendämpfungsprogramm für alle
energieintensiven Betriebe auf den Weg
bringen und insbesondere auch die
kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen stützen
wir können aber auch die dysfunktionalen
Energiemärkte die wir vorfinden nicht so
im Bestand lassen in einer solchen
Krisensituation geht es auch darum
zufallsgewinne abzuschöpfen deswegen
setze ich sehr auf die Verhandlung jetzt
im EU-Ministerrat kommende Woche die
werden alles andere als einfach denn man
kann natürlich auch schon
Ausweichbewegungen sehen auf den Märkten
die versuchen sich vor solchen
zufallsgewinnen abschöpfungen sozusagen
zu verstecken aber es ist notwendig dass
die Tatsache dass wir bei der Produktion
von Strom ganz andere Krediten finden
hat bei dem Verkauf dass wir daran gehen
und sagen das gehen wir zurück an die
Kunden an die Unternehmen damit ihr den
Strompreis unterkriegen größte Aufgabe
der Politik ist jetzt die Preise nach
unten zu bringen das haben wir mit einer
Ausweitung des Angebots bei LNG beim
Eingriff in Strommarkt bei dem
Hochfahren der Kohlekraftwerke all das
bringen wir auf den Weg und haben
entschlossen gehandelt in den letzten
Wochen
wer entlasten auch die energieintensiven
Unternehmen bereits jetzt über 1,7
Milliarden Euro Energie und Stromsteuer
durch die Verlängerung des
Spitzenausgleichs um ein Jahr die
Anpassung der insolvenzregelung ist in
Planung Unternehmen sollen nicht mehr
ihr Fortbestehen über die nächsten 12
sondern nur noch vier Monate nachweisen
auch das ist jetzt krisenrelevant dass
wir das tun und ganz zum Schluss möchte
ich aber auch das relevanteste eingehen
wir können jetzt abfedern wir können
helfen das tun wir mit der finanziellen
Stärke unseres Staates und ich bin der
Meinung wir sollten eher mehr
finanzielle Stärke nutzen als weniger in
einer solchen Krisensituation aber es
geht jetzt auch ganz darum das Thema
Energieeffizienz Zukunft Investitionen
heute im Handelsplatz ein gutes
edoterial dazu es ist auch eine Chance
in einer solchen Krise verborgen dass
wir uns jetzt wettbewerbsfähig
aufstellen und deswegen ist der Klima-
und transformationsfonds der
Bundesregierung der auf 35 Milliarden
erhöht worden ist ein relevantes
Instrument nach vorne zu schauen wir
müssen uns unabhängig machen russischer
Energie aber wir müssen auch jetzt die
ergreifen damit wir wettbewerbsfähig mit
erneuerbaren Energien Energieeffizienz
neuen Geschäftsmodellen und eine bessere
Zukunft schauen ich danke Ihnen
Dieter janitschek war das der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und ihm
wird jetzt in dieser Debatte über
energiepolitische Perspektiven für
Bürger und Unternehmen so hat die
Unionsfraktion ihren Antrag
überschrieben Janine Wissler
Parteivorsitzende der linken und
natürlich auch Mitglied der
Linksfraktion meine Damen und Herren
wenn man sich den Antrag der
Unionsfraktion anschaut dann reibt man
sich schon verwundert die Augen was sie
daran so alles fordern preisdeckel
staatliche Eingriffe in den Strommarkt
Verstaatlichung von kritischer
Infrastruktur Maßnahmen die sie bis vor
kurzem noch als sozialistisches
Teufelszeug geißelt hätten offenbar
merken auch Sie Herr Merz der Markt
regelt es eben nicht
ja die aktuelle Energiekrise ist eine
Folge verfehlter Energiepolitik die
Energiewende wurde verschleppt und
gerade sie von der Union haben vor Ort
oft gegen jedes neue Windrad gekämpft
sehenden Auges wurde dadurch die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energien und
von Energieimporten gefestigt wir
könnten längst bei 100% erneuerbaren
sein zumindest im Strombereich und dann
hätten wir diese fatale Abhängigkeit
nicht und wir werden deutlich weiter
beim Klimaschutz
meine Damen und Herren die Inflation
verschärft die Spaltung zwischen oben
und unten und sie stürzt viele Menschen
und viele Unternehmen in Existenz töte
und zu Recht gibt es deshalb Proteste
die ja auch erste Wirkung zeigen
immerhin bekommen jetzt auch Rentner und
Studierende Hilfe aber die
Einmalzahlungen verpuffen angesichts der
dauerhaft hohen Preise für Lebensmittel
und Energie und wir schlagen deshalb für
niedrige und mittlere Einkommen ein
monatliches inflationsgeld von
mindestens 125 Euro vor und eine
sofortige und deutliche Erhöhung der
Hartz-IV-Regelsätze das ist dringend
notwendig
aber auch das wird nicht reichen um die
explodierenden Gaspreise auszugleichen
dafür brauchen wir einen gaspreisdeckel
viele Menschen bekommen in diesen Tagen
Briefe von ihren Gasversorgern dass sich
ihre Abschlagszahlungen verdreifacht bis
verzehnfacht haben Familien und rentner
sollen dreistellige oder gar
vierstellige Beträge zahlen für Gas und
zwar monatlich das kann man durch
direkte Hilfen überhaupt nicht
ausgleichen dafür muss man die
Spekulation bekämpfen in den Strom
eingreifen und einen preisdeckel
einführen meine Damen und Herren Spanien
Portugal Belgien Großbritannien und
andere Länder tun das wo in Frankreich
dürfen die Energiepreise nur um vier
Prozent steigen wir fordern ein
kostengünstiges grundkontingent für
Strom und Gas sowie ein gesetzliches
Verbot von Strom und gassperren damit
niemand in diesem Land im Winter frieren
muss
und woher verbraucht muss im Gegenzug
deutlich teurer werden mit der gasumlage
wollen sie die Kosten für die graskrise
auf die Verbraucher abwälzen die
zufälligerweise mit gasheizen worauf wie
Mieterinnen und Mieter überhaupt kein
Einfluss haben und Sie haben ja selber
gemerkt dass das Quatsch ist aber den
nächsten Quatsch gleich hinterher
beschlossen nämlich die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer für alle gasgründen das
ist zwar teuer gleich aber die
Mehrkosten bei vielen die alte Verträge
haben überhaupt nicht aus die gasumlage
meine Damen und Herren ist Murks sie ist
falsch und deshalb muss sie abgeschafft
werden
es ist richtig
Herr Minister Habeck
Gasversorger zu retten und in die
staatliche Hand zu überführen um einen
Kollaps bei der Versorgung zu verhindern
das muss aber aus Steuermitteln erfolgen
und das sollte auch dauerhaft sein denn
Energieversorgung gehört als Teil der
öffentlichen Daseinsvorsorge in die
öffentliche Hand und unter demokratische
Kontrolle wieder einmal werden Verluste
sozialisiert und Gewinne privatisiert
einige Konzerne machen riesen Gewinne in
dieser Krise und deshalb brauchen wir
eine übergewinnsteuer die haben viele
Länder eingeführt die EU-Kommission
empfiehlt das sogar führen Sie die
endlich ein
meine Damen und Herren Finanzminister
Lindner beklagt dass es einsam um ihn
werde beim Festhalten an der Illusion
die Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr noch
einhalten zu können ja es ist nicht
ein eigene Weltbild auf die Realität
trifft den Kürzeren zieht und alle es
merken außer einem selbst die
Schuldenbremse muss ausgesetzt werden
besser noch abgeschafft werden wir
brauchen Investitionen in die
Energiewende den Ausbau des ÖPNV wir
brauchen Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz das ist die Verantwortung
gegenüber kommenden Generationen und
nicht das Klammern als einen anderen
offensichtlich schädliches Dogma vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin bissle
nächste Redner ist der Kollege Reinhard
Huben FDP-Fraktion und da ist er
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
eine Vorbemerkung zum Thema Dynamik von
Ministerien
meine erste Veranstaltung als Mitglied
des Deutschen Bundestags 2017 war eine
Debatte über der Reform des postgesetzes
wahrhaftig ein schwerwiegendes Thema
in den letzten vier Jahren ist es dem
letzten Wirtschaftsminister nicht
gelungen ein solches Gesetz auf die
Reihe zu bringen und dich finde es dann
schon starker ja dass sie diesem
Ministerium und diesen Minister
nun fehlende dynamikvorwerft also Sie
können ja mit den Entscheidungen nicht
in Einklang stehen das ist ja vollkommen
in Ordnung aber wenn ich sehe was dieses
Ministerium neben vielen anderen in der
Krise in unserem Land leisten ist sehr
dynamisch meine Damen und Herren da
brauchen wir uns überhaupt nicht perfekt
meine Damen und Herren ich bin selbst
Unternehmer mein Unternehmen handelt mit
elektroinstallationsmaterial und ich
habe mal zu Hause geguckt
wie hoch ist denn unser
Energiekostenanteil am Umsatz und der
ist so niedrig dass mein Unternehmen
keine Unterstützung braucht das heißt im
Umkehrschluss natürlich nicht dass es
die Bäckereien gibt das ist die
Ziegelhersteller gibt das ist die
Papierhersteller gibt und so weiter und
so fort diese müssen unterstützt werden
aber wenn die Wirtschaft selbst der
Mittelstand
gegenüber der KfW erklärt
zu mindestens 55 Prozent haben wir
natürlich Probleme mit steigenden
Energiekosten aber wir kommen damit klar
dann haben wir doch die Aufgabe Lösungen
zu finden die möglichst zielgenau sind
und da sind wir es ist ja eben
dargestellt worden auch mitten in der
Debatte und ich halte es nicht für klug
ich hatte es nicht für klug wie sie das
tun hier so ein Füllhorn an Lösungen für
unterschiedlichste Gruppierungen
auszuschütten ich frage mal liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
haben Sie eigentlich ihren Antrag mit
den Haushältern abgestimmt
haben sie das abgestimmt ich finde es
interessant sie eröffnen Möglichkeiten
zum Ausgeben von Geld im sackten
dreistelligen Milliarden
Milliardenbereich und die einzige
konkrete Finanzierung die sie
vorschlagen ist das eeg-konto wo im
Moment schätzungsweise 17-18 Milliarden
Euro liegen also deswegen halte ich den
Antrag an dieser Stelle nicht für sales
und wir müssen natürlich auch meine
Damen und Herren mit einer Illusion
aufhören
und das suggeriert ihr Antrag
wir werden selbst wenn wir diese Gas-
und Kohlekrise überstanden haben der
Weltmarktpreis vom Öl hat sich ja schon
relativ beruhigt wenn wir also diese
Krise überstanden haben
eins sicherlich nicht haben nämlich ein
Preisniveau für Energie wie es vor dem
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine war deswegen müssen wir und muss
auch die Wirtschaft selbst erkennen dass
bestimmte Geschäftsmodelle nur dann
funktionieren wenn entsprechend
preiswerte Energieträger eingebaut
werden und das sind natürlich zum großen
Teil auch sogenannte oder alternative
Energien
und zum Abschluss meine Damen und Herren
und zum Abschluss für Sie persönlicher
erlauben Sie mir auch eine Bemerkung wir
haben natürlich im Moment kein
Nachfrageproblem sondern ein
angebotsproblem und das gilt
selbstverständlich auch ja aber welche
Lösungen bieten sie denn in ihrem Antrag
was die Angebotsseite angeht da sehe ich
nicht sehr viel meine Damen und Herren
denn selbst die Union ist nicht in der
Lage den Gas Weltmarktpreis hier
festzulegen also das ist doch nur
wirklich nicht wahr und natürlich ändert
sich der Preis wenn das Angebot erhöht
wird deswegen werden ja lng-terminals
gebaut in Deutschland dazu waren sie
außerdem in den letzten Jahren auch
nicht in der Lage mal so als nebenbei
Bemerkung in ihren jeweiligen
Koalitionen und sicherlich ist es
kurzfristig für die nächsten zwei Winter
sinnvoll die Atomkraftwerke die zwei bis
drei die einsatzfähig sind auch länger
laufen zu lassen in dem Sinne vielen
Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
Reinhard Huben war das
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion der auch noch mal betont
hat das nicht alle Unternehmen gleich
betroffen sind von steigenden
Energiepreisen und er hat auch noch mal
betont die Bedeutung erneuerbarer
Energien für die Zukunft Julia Klöckner
ist ein Pult wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecherin der Unionsfraktion
Präsident Herr Minister haberk liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
erlebe dein grünes Wirtschaftswunder das
haben die Grünen plakatiert im
Bundestagswahlkampf
und Robert oder Landtagswahlkampf soll
mir auch recht sein Robert Habeck hat
dieses Wunder dieser Tage dann noch mal
konkretisiert und ich zitiere es wie er
sich dieses grüne Wirtschaftswunder
vorstellt wenn mit dem gasparen alles
gut geht und wir Glück mit dem Wetter
haben dann haben wir eine Chance gut
durch diesen Winter zu kommen aber ich
kann Ihnen sagen in dieser schwierigen
Situation brauchen wir keinen
bundesschamanen der da gutes Wetter
hofft sondern wir brauchen einen
Wirtschaftsminister der die richtigen
Entscheidungen in dieser Situation
trifft
und lieber Herr Huben
und auch Herr Janecek sie sprechen davon
was sie alles Vorhaben und bauen wollen
nur von Versprechungen und Ankündigungen
kann kein Metzger kann kein
Busunternehmen kann kein Bäcker kann
kein Handwerker seine Rechnungen
bezahlen und deshalb wenn Sie sich
diesen Antrag mal durchlesen sie sagen
welche Vorschläge haben Sie denn
vielleicht hat man Ihnen im Büro die
falschen Unterlagen vorgelegt ich kenne
unseren Antrag wir schlagen zum Beispiel
vor dass die Biomasse dass der Deckel
bei der Biomasse einfach mal wegkommt
wenn es heißt mal in darum haben sie
denn da einen Deckel drauf und wenn sie
die Anita erweitern wollen vom Strom die
Angebotsseite erweitern wollen und dass
am Ende der Preis sinkt ja warum setzen
sie denn jetzt durch dass die
Atomkraftwerke die Kernkraftwerke lange
länger laufen damit kriegen wir es hin
steht im Antrag drin ich finde das
ziemlich konkret lieber Herr hugend und
dann will ich auch mal mit zwei drei
Märchen hier auch aufräumen das ist ja
ihre ganze Leier die ganze Zeit da
halten sich ja fest wie wir an
irgendeinem Gerüst sie sprechen die
ganze Zeit davon wir hätten keine LNG
Terminals gebaut mir sind die Grünen
nicht aufgefallen in vergangenen zwei
Jahrzehnten dass sie die Kämpfer und
Demonstranten waren für lng-terminals im
Gegenteil entgegenteil war es und dann
sage ich noch mal was zu Herrn gremmels
was sie meinten mit Bayern die Leier
klappt ja auch nicht mehr ganz laut
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ist das
Bundesland mit den meisten erneuerbaren
Energien der Freistaat Bayern
Bundesland Nummer eins bei der Biomasse
Nummer eins bei der Photovoltaik Nummer
1 bei der Geothermie und wenn wir uns
bei der Windkraft sind wir vor dem
grünen Baden-Württemberg also ins
ofern Schrott mit
offenen Bayern ein bisschen schwierig
und deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen die ist schlichtweg
dramatisch es sind explodierende
Energiepreise und es geht auch um die
Energieversorgung es geht ja nicht mehr
nur um den Preis sondern auch darum dass
jetzt mittlerweile Unternehmen gar
keinen Vertrag mehr angeboten bekommen
und natürlich sagt die Bundesnetzagentur
wir müssen um 20% unserem Gasverbrauch
senken die Industrie hat das geschafft
aber das ist nicht nur Grund zur Freude
denn ein Drittel fährt daher rührt daher
dass Unternehmen ihre Produktion
eingestellt haben und deshalb kein Gas
mehr brauchen das geht an die Substanz
das geht an die Lebenswerke das geht an
unser Wohlstand das geht an die
wirtschaftsfähigkeit dieses Landes und
die Wettbewerbsfrage wird ganz neu
gestellt aber dass sie in dieser Zeit
noch nicht mal als zither-ratifizieren
sondern diese Woche schon wieder von der
Tagesordnung nehmen das zeigt doch dass
sie die ganze Zeit nur am schwätzen sind
und nichts machen und davon kann kein
Unternehmen die mitarbeiterlöhne
bezahlen die Erzeugerpreise sind 46%
höher als Anfänger und das ist der
höchste Wert seit Beginn der Statistik
und dann schaue ich mir noch mal die das
nächste Märchen an die cdu/csu hat uns
in die Abhängigkeit von Russland
gebracht also besonderes sind subtilen
für Humor haben sie ja muss ich sagen
ein paar Namen nennen aus der
SPD-Fraktion die sind sehr sehr eng ich
weiß nicht ob sie Russisch sprechen aber
es Geld können sie annehmen da kann ich
Ihnen auch sehr deutsch sagen 2014
Anfrage an den damaligen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel
bei den Verkauf des erdgasspeichers an
den russischen Gazprom eine das
Unternehmen da war die Antwort eine
Unterbrechung russischen Erdgas
russischer Erdgaslieferung hätte laut
Bundesregierung keine schädlichen Folgen
beziehungsweise sei unbedenklich also
wenn sie in die Geschichtsbücher gucken
dann gucken Sie mal genauer rein sie
waren beteiligt und deshalb damit möchte
ich schließen will ich sehr klar sagen
es geht darum dass wir die Angebotsseite
erweitern dass wir ein schwarzes Preis
für Gas einführen und dass wir vor allen
Dingen die kalte Progression jetzt
rückwirkend auch vor allen Dingen
ausgleichen und den Unternehmen helfen
mit super abtreiben und mit besseren
denn am Ende geht es uns überleben und
nicht uns diskutieren
jawohl
ich war jetzt sehr gängig nächster
Redner ist der Kollege Andreas
Mehltretter SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der britische
Guardian hat letzte Woche Goldman 6
zitiert der Gaspreis könnte sich bis zum
Ende des Winters wieder halbieren der
Grund die gemeinsamen europäischen
Anstrengungen sein erfolgreich sie
würden einen gasmangel im Winter
verhindern es ist sicher viel zu früh um
wirklich Entwarnung zu geben und es ist
uns völlig bewusst die BürgerInnen die
Bürger und die Unternehmen stehen vor
riesigen Herausforderungen bei denen sie
Unterstützung brauchen es ist aber auch
klar es ist die Arbeit unserer
Ampelkoalition die tatsächlich eine
ermutigende energiepolitische
Perspektive gibt
es ist die Ampelkoalition die dafür
gesorgt hat dass sie garspeicher fast
komplett gefüllt sind es ist die
Ampelkoalition die entlastungspakete von
mittlerweile 95 Milliarden Euro auf dem
Weg gebracht hat und es ist die Ampel
Koalition die den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien deutlich
beschleunigt hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Union
wer nur markige Sprüche ohne jede
Substanz von der Seitenauslinie aufs
Spielfeld brüllt der muss sich schon
fragen lassen warum er eigentlich noch
ernst genommen werden sollte sie werfen
uns in dem Antrag eine verfehlte
Krisenpolitik vor während sie vieles
fordern was wir sowieso gerade schon
umsetzen verstehen sie das unter
ernsthafter Oppositionsarbeit sie nennen
uns Verhinderer verhindern aber
gleichzeitig immer noch mit Vorgaben
wieder 10h-regelungen Bayern den Ausbau
der Windenergie merken Sie eigentlich
dass das nicht so wirklich zusammenpasst
und sie sind nicht einmal sich zu schade
und sie in ihrem Antrag vorzuwerfen wir
würden bewusst Blackouts in Kauf nehmen
diesen verleumberischen Populismus
können Sie sparen Liebe Union
wie wollen Sie denn eigentlich die
erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen dazu
steht in dem Antrag nichts sie denken
immer noch ausschließlich Fossil das
wird hier wieder mal deutlich mit den
fossilen allein werden wir aber die
Krise nicht bewältigen gut dass sie
nicht mehr im Kanzleramt und im
Wirtschaftsministerium sitzen
meine Damen und Herren wie sieht denn
die Lage wirklich aus der letzte
Stresstest hat gezeigt dass wir doch aus
bei der Energieversorgung ein Problem
haben nämlich Länder mit schwarzen
Regierungsparteien im Süden Deutschlands
sie haben den Ausbau der Windkraft
verhindert sie haben den Ausbau der
Stromnetze verändert und sie tun jetzt
ja immer noch so als wären
Kernkraftwerke mit Leckagen die Lösung
für alle Probleme obwohl sie selbst 2011
den Ausstieg als guten Gründen besiedelt
haben
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen die
Versorgung mit Strom und Gas
sicherstellen timo gremmels hat gerade
sehr deutlich gemacht was wir dafür
alles tun und warum wir damit so
erfolgreich sind dass sogar Friedrich
Merz branchenfreunde uns loben wir
wissen aber natürlich dass die
Energiepreise viele gerade vor
existenzielle Herausforderungen stellen
wir wissen dass wir noch nicht überall
die notwendige Unterstützung leisten
aber wir werden dafür sorgen dass
niemand von den Energiepreisen
überfordert ist wir werden niemanden
alleine lassen das gilt
ein reduzierter Preis für den
Grundbedarf an Strom der kommt ein
reduzierter Preis für den Grundbedarf an
Gas darum wird doch gerade mit Hochdruck
gearbeitet und die notwendige
Unterstützung für kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen die bringt es
Wirtschaftsministerium gerade auf den
Weg Herr Kollege erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
meine Damen und Herren das alles was
hier die Union fordert haben wir schon
lange mit dem Entlastungspaket drei
beschlossen wir haben diese Wochen diese
Woche auch die ersten Gesetze zur
Umsetzung in den Bundestag eingebracht
wir haben eine wohngeldreform und das
neue Bürgergeld auf dem Weg gebracht wir
setzen unsere Zusagen jetzt Stück für
Stück um das ist seriöse Politik
ganz im Gegenteil zu dem unseriösen
Schauspiel das sie aufführen hier im
Bundestag lamentieren sie das alles
nicht schnell genug geht und
gleichzeitig verhindern sie mit ihren
Ministerpräsidenten im Bundesrat dass
das Entlastungspaket schnell umgesetzt
wird sie behindern Entlastungen anstatt
sie mit uns voranzutreiben so schaut es
aus
Liebe Union vor der Sommerpause haben
sie gedroht vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht zu klagen wenn
wir wegen der Energiekrise die
Schuldenbremse noch einmal aussetzen
würden
gleichzeitig fordern Sie jetzt dutzende
Milliarden an weiteren Entlastungen in
diesem Antrag ohne ein Wort zur
Gegenfinanzierung vom eg-konto abgesehen
was gilt denn nun oder kann sein dass
sie einfach gerne Forderungen Aufstehen
die logisch gar nicht zusammen gehen
meine Damen und Herren wir stehen vor
einer extrem schwierigen Situation wir
müssen alles Erforderliche tun damit wir
gemeinsam gut durch die Krise kommen
vieles haben wir schon beschlossen und
umgesetzt einiges wird noch kommen
wir sorgen dafür uns auf den Punkt zu
bringen dass sie Lichter und die
Heizungen nicht ausgehen und das niemand
von den Rechnungen dafür überfordert
wird darauf können Sie sich verlassen
danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
dr malte Kaufmann afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren viele Bürger in
Deutschland machen sich zurzeit zu recht
große Sorgen wegen eines drohenden
Blackouts Millionen Menschen sind
entsetzt über die immer weiter
steigenden Preise für Strom Heizung
Benzin und Güter des täglichen Bedarfs
aber nicht nur die Bürger trifft es auch
die Wirtschaft leidet extrem unter den
hohen Preisen erste Traditionsfirmen
sind schon insolvent es wurde
angesprochen eine Pleitewelle droht
dahinter stecken Schicksale von
tausenden Unternehmerfamilien und
Hunderttausenden Angestellten die ihre
Arbeit verlieren werden
nicht selten zerrinnt derzeit das
unternehmerische Werk von Generationen
innerhalb kürzester Zeit zwischen den
Fingern
in einer derart krisenhaften Situationen
muss doch das Gebot der Stunde lauten
alle Register müssen gezogen werden alle
verfügbaren Energielieferanten müssen
genutzt werden damit diese dramatische
Preisspirale gestoppt wird
und deshalb ja die Windkraft die im
Moment verfügbar ist natürlich aber auch
was die CDU fordert die drei derzeit
noch in Betrieb befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
das wäre das Gebot der Stunde meine
Damen und Herren
und als afd-fraktion geht das uns nicht
weit genug legen sie endlich ihre
ideologischen Scheuklappen ab und machen
Sie moderne Kerntechnologie in
Deutschland wieder grundsätzlich möglich
im
unionsantrag sind weitere Punkte
enthalten die wir schon lange fordern
zum einen die Absenkung von stromsteuern
und Netzentgelten und zum anderen auch
die Rücknahme der unsäglichen gasumlage
schaffen Sie die wieder ab
und Herr Minister Habeck sie haben am
Mittwoch Ehrlichkeit und
Verantwortungsbereitschaft eingefordert
dabei sind sie es damit seiner
verschleppungstaktik in Bezug auf die
Kernkraftwerke zutiefst
verantwortungslos agiert
zumindest hat ihre Rede gezeigt dass
ihre Nerven ganz offensichtlich blank
liegen sie sind als Wirtschaftsminister
vollkommen überfordert wenn man nicht
wenn man in dieser Situation nicht mal
weiß was eine Insolvenz ist
sie ahnen wahrscheinlich dass das
drohende Desaster für Deutschland für
immer mit ihrem Namen mit dem Namen
ihrer Partei verbunden sein wird den
Kollegen der FDP sei gesagt wenn Sie
sich dieses politische Schicksal
ersparen wollen beenden Sie das endlose
Chaos und schalten Sie nicht die
Kernkraftwerke ab sondern schalten Sie
diese unsägliche Ampel ab das wäre ein
großer Dienst für unser Land vielen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
als nächste Rednerin hält das Wort die
Kollegin Sandra detzer
sehr verehrter Präsident meine Kollegen
und Kollegen der Hashtag danke Habeck
trendet diese Tage auf Twitter und es
ist auch völlig klar
[Applaus]
Krisen die stirnbiete statt sie nur
auszusitzen und das Ernsthaftigkeit und
Schnelligkeit ganz genau passt zu den
massiven Sorgen der Menschen und vieler
Betriebe in diesem Land und ja das tut
weh ich glaube nicht dass sie ihm das
weh tut Liebe Union ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal die Überschrift Ihres
Antrags liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Union und ich dekliniere das mal
durch Punkt eins wir geben BürgerInnen
eine energiepolitische Perspektive wir
sichern akut die Gasversorgung vieler
hunderte Stadtwerke ab indem wir die
uniper stabilisieren und damit
millionenhaushaltever Kälte und
Dunkelheit bewahren wir bauen einen
g-terminals sind rekordgezeit und wir
haben das größte auswahlpaket für die
Erneuerbaren beschlossen damit
durchbrechen wir endlich den Fluch des
gasfetisch mit dem die Union dieses Land
an den Rand der Funktionsfähigkeit
geführt hat
Punkt 2 wir bringen die Preise unter
Kontrolle
wir führen eine strompreisbremse ein die
die Kosten für Haushalt und KMU für den
basisverbrauch senkt wir bereiten die
gaspreisbremse vor damit mit einem fixen
Preis für den Grundbedarf und
Marktpreise für alles was darüber
hinausgeht und wir senken die
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas um ganz unmittelbar
Gaspreise zu senken und der dritte Punkt
auch wieder die Überschrift dass sie im
Antrag wir verhindern insolvenzellen der
Rettungsschirm für energieintensive
Unternehmen wird ausgeweitet auf alle
Branchen im Mittelstand im Handwerk
damit greifen wir rund einer Million
Betriebe unter die Arme die momentan
eben nicht wissen wie es weitergeht
jetzt fehlt da nur noch die Zusage des
Finanzministers der Vorschlag des bmwk
liegt auf dem Tisch und dann werden wir
den unverzüglich umsetzen
die Lage ist ernst meine Damen und
Herren und es ist gut dass es in diesem
Land endlich einen Wirtschaftsminister
gibt der dieser Aufgabe gewachsen ist
herzlichen Dank
Sandra der Zahn macht noch mal Werbung
für den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
jetzt ist wieder doch noch mal Schwung
gekommen in diese Debatte und ich
vermute mal das wird sich jetzt gleich
fortsetzen zumindest was die emotionale
Lage angeht argumentativ hören wir ja
hier in dieser Debatte nicht so
dramatisch viel Neues in den vergangenen
Minuten Thema in Kuban ist am Pult für
die Unionsfraktion und noch ist der ja
auch Vorsitzender der Jungen Union Frau
Kollegin detzer sie haben mal wieder
gezeigt dass die Twitter leider nicht
verstanden haben aber in dieser Woche
haben wir eh schon einiges erlebt der
dunnhäutige Minister Habeck hier mit
seinem hat in seiner Rede gefragt ob wir
hier im Fußballstadion sein
um es um ein Fußballspiel zu gewinnen
Herr Minister muss man nicht den
Gegenspieler anbrüllen oder wie sie dann
Kopfstöße verteilen sondern eine
Spielidee haben neue Spielzüge einüben
und gute Mitspieler haben und ich sage
Ihnen um Tore zu schießen da braucht man
einen anderen Weg ihre Politik der
gasumlage erinnert mich ehrlicherweise
ein bisschen mehr an Andi Möller Mailand
oder Madrid Hauptsache Italien es war
ein klassisches Eigentor
und die Zahlen
[Applaus]
und die Zahlen der gasumlage sind ja
auch beeindruckend sie zahlen jetzt 8
Milliarden Euro an das finnische
Staatsunternehmen Forum zur Rettung von
Juniper das kann man hier in Deutschland
eigentlich kaum jemandem erklären sie
belasten danach einseitig die Gaskunden
mit einer Umlage und ich frage mich
manches Mal wer will diese Umlage
eigentlich in diesem Haus wer will diese
Umlage eigentlich in Deutschland wenn
sie erklären vorher den Leuten Gas sei
die Brücke in die Zukunft sie sollen
ihre alte Ölheizung rausschmeißen und
belasten dann einseitig die Gaskunden
das ist keine solidarische Politik die
sie da machen
und wenn sie dann
und wenn sie dann sich hinstellen in
diesem Haus und lamentieren bei der
Windkraft ja es sei nicht alles
vorangegangen ich sage es Ihnen die
verbandsklagerechte und die
naturschutzvorgaben das waren keine
Erfindung der CDU am Ende sage ich Ihnen
auch jeder Rotmilan in diesem Land den
sie immer schützen wollten hat mehr
Windkraftanlagen verhindert als der
Bürgerprotest vor Ort es war ihre
Meinung die sie vorangetrieben haben
Frau Dr detzer auch in Baden-Württemberg
und wir und wir legen heute konkrete
Konzepte vor ein Dreiklang das Angebot
zu erhöhen die Preise zu senken und die
besonders hart Betroffenen in diesem
Land zu entlasten was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist die Erhöhung eines Angebotes
und der Bundeskanzler hat gesagt man
muss alles tun um dieses Angebot zu
erhöhen aber wo ist es denn wo ist denn
die nationale Kraftanstrengung die sie
erklärt haben ob bei zu Atom bei Kohle
bei Biomasse bei neuen Gasquellen bei
Windkraft bei PV oder bei Geothermie sie
reden nur sie machen nicht das ist unser
Vorwurf es ist fehlanzeige
was Deutschland jetzt braucht ist eine
Preisbremse für den Strommarkt wir haben
das Thema merit order Prinzip und die
Frage Herr Kollege janitschek auch in
unserem Antrag angepriesen zu sagen es
braucht ein europäischen
Großhandelspreis fürs Gas deswegen der
europäische Bezug ist durchaus da wenn
Sie den Antrag gelesen hätten was sie
bisher machen um die Entspannung auf dem
Strommarkt zu sorgen ist bisher
Fehlanzeige was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist ein industriestrompreis die
Arbeitsplätze bei den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen die sind
im wanken Millionen von Menschen fragen
sich ob sie im nächsten Jahr noch ihren
Job behalten die Franzosen und
Niederländer haben es bereits eingeführt
und wenn ich daran erinnern darf dann
war es der Bundeskanzler der im letzten
Jahr ein industriesturmpreis von vier
Cent hier versprochen hat der Industrie
ich frage mich wo ist dieser
industriestrompreis am Ende fehlanzeige
was Deutschland was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist dass sie aufhören dass sie
aufhören die besonders hart Betroffenen
zu vergessen erst die Studenten und die
Rentner jetzt bei diesem Malz vor allem
die kleinen Einkommen sie entlasten die
Arbeit sehr entlasten haben die
wohngeld-empfänger und sie entlasten ab
35 40.000 Euro diejenigen diejenigen bei
der Abmeldung der kalten Progression wen
Sie vergessen haben sind die kleinen
Einkommen die kleinen Einkommen in
diesem Land diejenigen die jeden Tag
aufstehen zur Arbeit gehen und ihre
Kinder zur Kita bringt die wirklich
malochen dass das eine SPD in diesem
Land vergisst ist ein echter Skandal und
keine Fehlanzeige und deswegen folgen
Sie unserem Antrag wir geben 1000 Euro
für kleine Einkommen das ist der
richtige Weg danke schön
vielen Dank herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Herr
kubanisch gratuliere zu einer tollen
Rede für Youtube es wäre schön wenn es
ein bisschen seriöser und mehr Fakten
orientiert gegangen wäre aber das können
sie gut teilen da freue ich mich für sie
ich würde gerne zu Ihrem Antrag
zurückkommen ich bin nämlich immer ganz
begeistert wenn die Union in Antrag hier
vorlegt war ich immer ganz gespannt bin
ob man da im Bausch und Bogen verwerfen
muss oder ob man auch Ansätze in der
konstruktiven
Oppositionsarbeit findet letzteres ist
selten aber es gibt richtige Punkte und
richtige Ansätze in diesem Antrag ich
werde gleich darauf eingehen ob die dann
immer realistisch gegen finanziert sind
und ob sie das jetzt nur einfach nur
fordern obwohl sie schon auf den Weg
gebracht haben ist noch mal die nächste
Frage aber einiges aus diesem Antrag ist
durchaus zu gebrauchen wir haben ja
schon bei Grundsätzen das Problem wenn
Sie sich hier hinstellen naja es geht
Schnelligkeit und Zielgenauigkeit und
wir brauchen jetzt sofort wirksame
Maßnahmen jetzt klingt super kann man so
sagen aber in der Praxis ist natürlich
die Frage wie macht man es und wenn man
zum Beispiel bei der Energiepreis
pauschale gesagt hätte wir klammern
Einkommen und ab einer gewissen Höhe aus
hätten wir viele viele Monate gebraucht
Einkommensteuererklärung und so weiter
und so weiter um das umzusetzen es
klingt super das zielgenau zu machen
aber dann wäre das Geld in 18 Monaten
gekommen und nicht jetzt und
dementsprechend muss man sich manchmal
entscheiden
die Bundesregierung und die Koalition
handeln wir haben es schon mehrfach
gehört heute Kurzarbeitergeld und ich
werde in jeder rede hier sagen weil es
eins der Meisterstücke der Regierung war
der alten und der jetzigen ist es
Energiekosten dämpfungsgesetz und auch
Maßnahmen für kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen wir kommen im Detail noch
drauf hier ist übrigens ganz besonders
wichtig dass wir Solo-Selbstständige
nicht vergessen die vergessen wir nicht
aber in der Ausgestaltung der Programme
und in der konkreten
antragsgelegenheiten muss das
entsprechend abgedeckt sein und ein
Thema was uns alle besonders umtreibt
zumindest diese Seite des Hauses sind
die Frage von Strom und gassperren das
ist gut und richtig dass die Regierung
vereinbart hat dass diese zu vermeiden
sind und wir erwarten darf ich ganz
ausdrücklich sagen von der
Bundesregierung hier auch eine
entsprechend schnelle Umsetzung weil
Menschen denen im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes der Saft abgedreht wird sind die
aller ärmsten und da brauchen wir sehr
schnell Fortschritte
wie ich schon gesagt habe sind einige an
Punkte Ihres Antrags nicht verkehrt zwar
ich persönlich nie Fan der
gaspreisumlage ich glaube dass wir eine
sozialgerechte Ausgestaltung brauchen
und insbesondere seit der
Verstaatlichung von uniper eine andere
Ausgangslage haben ich bin froh dass
Robert Habeck eine schnelle juristische
Prüfung an gedrängt hat und
angestoßen hat und freue mich da und
gehe von schnellen Ergebnissen und
Reaktionen aus ebenso gehe ich davon aus
dass die Kommission zum Thema Gaspreis
ihrer Verantwortung gerecht wird und
schnell zu konkreten Lösungen kommt die
wir dann auch schnell umsetzen können
ich muss dringend in diesem Jahr noch
sein ich bin hochbegeistert und das
gemeine ich gar nicht gar nicht
schnippisch dass sie in den
gaspreisdeckel für den Grundbedarf vorne
das habe ich hier im Juni schon mal
gesagt da wurde von ihnen noch herzlich
gelacht und das irgendwie als nette
Forderung des DGB kommentiert Ende Juli
ist Herr Spahn dann drauf aufgesprungen
ich freue mich das ist mittlerweile
fordern ob sie es umsetzen würden wenn
sie selber regieren würden darf man
vielleicht noch mal hinterfragen glaube
aber dass das richtig ist dass wir hier
auf dem Weg zu einem Konsens sind leider
und das ist das aber in der Frage
bleiben sie die Gegenfinanzierung halt
schuldig und dieses Muster setzt sich
fort sie sagen Netzentgelte für 2023
aussetzen die Stromsteuer auf den
eu-mindestsatz Senken etc kann man alles
machen aber wie die machen wir das denn
ohne Steuererhöhungen und neue Schulden
das alleine und das haben wir auch schon
mehrfach gehört in den letzten Tagen
Verzicht auf die gasumlage würde 34
Milliarden kosten die müssen irgendwo
herkommen und wenn ihr
inflationsvorsitzenden der nicht mehr da
ist heute auf N24 gesehen habe sieht man
auch dass es ihnen überhaupt nicht um
Lösungen geht da stellt sich Herr Merz
hin und sagt die Schuldenbremse ist
Gesetz das müssen wir machen im übrigen
wurden die Länder von dem
Entlastungspaket überrannt das heißt sie
suggerieren sogar dass das was wir
machen wo wir seit einer Stunde hören
das ist alles zu wenig doch irgendwie zu
viel und wir können uns nicht leisten
sie hören Sie mit diesem zündeln auf und
hören Sie auf diese moralisch zu agieren
weil es wirklich nicht glaubwürdig ist
wenn man sich die Details anschaut
und wir müssen die wirtschaftspolitische
Situation größer denken wir haben ein
angebotsschock auch das habe ich hier im
Juni gesagt da wurde auch noch groß
gejohlt auf der Seite das haben wir
verstanden und der hat jetzt auch zu
einem nachfrageschock geführt der
gfkonsumklimaindex denkt damit die
Nachfrage und damit ist klar dass wir
Anreize für die Konjunktur brauchen und
die Situation sich jetzt gravierend
verschärfen wird ich bin froh dass es
erste Maßnahmen zur Schaffung dieser
Nachfrage gibt und ebenso ist jetzt
unsere Hauptaufgabe den Kollaps des
Energiesystems zu verhindern es ist
wichtig dass wir die Energieversorgung
sicherstellen und beim Bedarf auch
kraftvoll zupacken uniper ist hier für
das beste Beispiel klar ist dass es nur
eine Übergangslösung sein kann aber auch
da hatten wir die Diskussion im Juni mit
Blick zum Beispiel auf die bayerische
Wasserkraft die die CSU 2003
verscherbelt hat weil man halt Geld für
den Bundeshaushalt gebracht hat wirklich
visionäre Energiepolitik sieht anders
aus und die Situation jetzt gibt auch
Chancen Fehler der Vergangenheit zu
korrigieren
kommunale Daseinsvorsorge ist bei der
Frage der Energiesicherheit niemals zu
vernachlässigen im Gegenteil ich glaube
sie kann gar nicht hoch genug bewertet
werden die Münchner Stadtwerke das war
jetzt Abgeordnete aus München mal sagen
sind hier in leuchtendes Beispiel wie
man es hinkriegt sich über viele Jahre
Visionär an Klimaschutz an
Klimaneutralität im kommunaler Hand zu
orientieren und wir sollten bei
Zukunftsfragen des Energiemarktes auch
mehr über Kommunalisierung und die
Stärkung der Daseinsvorsorge nachdenken
dass wir den Antrag trotz einiger guter
Punkte nicht mittragen können wird sie
nicht wahnsinnig überraschen vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
Sebastian Roloff aus der SPD-Fraktion
hat jetzt gerade mal bewiesen dass wir
den Antrag der Unionsfraktion doch recht
gründlich gelesen hat und er sogar
einige Ruhe in die rein der Union
bekommen weil er nämlich den ein oder
anderen Punkt gar nicht so uninteressant
fand wir sind bei Andreas Lenz noch mal
Unionsfraktion dritt letzter Redner in
dieser Debatte Sprecher für Klimaschutz
und Energie
die Versorgung und gerade jetzt in einer
Zeit von
Energieknappheit müssen wir alles aber
auch wirklich alles machen um die
Angebotsseite bei der Energieversorgung
zu stärken wir müssen Potenziale bei den
Erneuerbaren heben aber eben auch bei
den konventionellen Kapazitäten die
entlasten damit die Energie und
insbesondere die Strompreise wir helfen
damit den Verbrauchern den Unternehmen
dem Handwerk und dem Mittelstand und
diese Hilfe ist dringend notwendig und
es geht wirklich um jede Kilowattstunde
der Minister hat es ja mehrmals selbst
gesagt es ist eben auch eine stromkrise
das ist mittlerweile hoffentlich jedem
klar lassen Sie also die AKWs am Netz
hören Sie auf die Stellungnahmen im
Stresstest und der Verbände machen sie
alles um ernsthafte netzschwierigkeiten
im schlimmsten Fall einen Blick out zu
verhindern
und sie tun ja häufig so als ob das
irgendeinen Mantra der Union sei sonst
würde das ja niemand fordern niemand
sagen hören sie auf den
Sachverständigenrat der Bundesregierung
das sagt das sprechen Sie mit Frau
Professor Grimm das sagt übrigens auch
ihr Koalitionspartner die FDP das sagt
auch dass europäische Ausland sie sind
doch auch im energieministerrat das
sagen selbst grüne Abgeordnete im
Europaparlament beispielsweise der
schwedische Europaabgeordneter take
anstatt der Deutschland vorwirft keine
Verantwortung für die Energiesicherheit
zu übernehmen nehmen Sie diese Stimme
ernst wenn sie schon uns nicht glauben
lassen Sie die Kernkraftwerke befristet
am Netz überwinden Sie an dieser Stelle
ihrer Ideologie sie sparen damit weiter
Gas und entlasten den Markt und die
Preise es droht es droht die die
Industrialisierung Deutschlands und ich
rate jedem das entsprechend ernst zu
nehmen es war immer
es war immer das Produzieren der Gewerbe
das uns über Krisen der Vergangenheit
getragen hat sei es die Finanz- und
Wirtschaftskrise oder auch andere Krisen
und übrigens wenn die Industrie aus
Deutschland verschwindet dann kann und
dann gibt es auch nichts mehr zu
transformieren hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Wirtschaft dann ist sie
einfach weg die Emissionen sind aber
nicht weg die Emissionen entstehen dann
an anderen Orten der Welt also schützen
sie den Mittelstand schützen Sie das
Handwerk durch Entlassungen an ein
höheres Angebot an Energie
ansonsten verspielen sie den Wohlstand
dieses Landes meine Damen und Herren
handeln Sie also es sind übrigens erst
zwei Kohlekraftwerke wieder ans Netz
gegangen die bezauber brauchen hier
Planungssicherheit nicht nur für diesen
Winter wir werden auch im übernächsten
Winter eine Energieknappheit haben und
außerdem stärken sie die Erneuerbaren
wir haben es da haben Sie unseren ihrer
Seite unsere Vorschläge liegen auf dem
Tisch beim Biogas Deck wir haben heute
morgen bei der Anhörung noch weitere
Vorschläge die auch unseren Vorschlägen
entsprachen gehört setzen Sie diese um
die Vorschläge liegen auf dem Tisch
der Minister hat ja gestern gesagt dass
weitere Entlastungen notwendig sind und
kommen werden darauf hoffen wir aber
fangen Sie doch zunächst einmal damit an
dass sie nicht weiter belasten nehmen
Sie diese vermurkste gasumlage von vom
Tisch gerade jetzt wo uniper ja
verstaatlicht wird und wenn ich die
Diskussion mir vergegenwärtige gerade
auch die letzten Beiträge dann stelle
ich mir die Frage wer in diesem
Parlament ist denn eigentlich noch für
die gasumlage wir steht denn noch zu
diesem Konzept es ist aus meiner Sicht
immer noch so wie bei einer Jacke die
man falsch beginnt einzuknöpfen das wird
meistens nicht besser wenn man weiter
zuknöpft
entknöpfen Sie diese Jacke schaffen Sie
die gasumlage ab und nehmen Sie diesen
Vorschlag vom Tisch und entlasten bzw
belasten sie somit die Verbraucher nicht
noch mehr herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Andreas Lenz
war das
Sprecher für Klimaschutz und Energie aus
der CSU-Landesgruppe hat er gesprochen
und wir sind beim vorletzten Redner
Felix bannaschak Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und Kollegen Deutschland steht zweifels
ohne vor großen wirtschaftspolitischen
Herausforderungen die Energiepreise die
Energie Verfügbarkeit die Inflation die
drohende Rezession der Fachkräftemangel
der Fachkräftemangel betrifft das
Handwerk betrifft Teile der Industrie
und ganz offensichtlich betrifft der
Fachkräftemangel auch die cdu/cs zur
Bundestagsfraktion anders kann ich mir
anders kann ich mir nicht erklären mir
wäre das unangenehm mir wäre das
unangenehmen
der Wirtschaftsminister handelt wie ein
wirtschaftspolitischer Praktikant Frau
schlöckner sie haben gerade von einem
Schamanen gesprochen ich würde mich
schämen den Minister der gerade in
Karren aus dem Dreck zieht zu
beschimpfen und dann so eine dünne Suppe
zu gewinnen so eine dünne Suppe wie
dieser Antrag
zwei Seiten zwei Seiten voller
Widersprüche zwei Seiten voller
Widersprüche sie müssen sich schon
entscheiden sie waren hier 16 Jahre lang
eine staatstragende Regierung und haben
sich jetzt für eine klamau-opposition
entschieden die dieser epochalen
Herausforderung vor denen wir stehen
einfach nicht gerecht wird sie können
doch nicht ernsthaft
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft in einem
solchen Antrag schreiben wir wollen eine
gaspreisdeckel müssen wir nicht wie wir
es bezahlen wollen wir wollen keine
gasumlage keine gasumlage ohne irgendwie
zu diskutieren was denn die Alternative
wäre was ist ihre alternative wollen sie
wollen sie die Gasversorger pleite gehen
lassen wollen Sie dass die Stadtwerke
pleite gehen wollen Sie dass die
Energieversorgung ausfällt oder wollen
sie das Geld woanders lernen diese Frage
müssen sie beantworten aber das was sie
mit das was sie mit diesem Antrag und
was sie mit allen Reden in dieser Woche
gemacht haben ist immer nur nein keine
gasumlage keine neuen Steuern keine
neuen Schulden das ist ein
mathematisches Ding der Unmöglichkeit
und ich frage mich wie wenig ernst
nehmen kann man sich denn als Opposition
in einer zoepochalen Krise
sie sprechen sie sprechen in diesem
Antrag von einer energiepolitischen
Perspektive für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und die Unternehmen diese
energiepolitische Perspektive ist
angesprochen worden geben wir wir bauen
das muss man noch mal anerkennen grüner
Wirtschaftsminister baut reihenweise
lng-terminals auch schaffen neue fossile
Fachschaft neue fossile Infrastrukturen
lässt Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen
bringt AKWs in einen Reservebetrieb um
kurzfristig zu agieren aber meine Damen
und Herren da draußen demonstrieren
heute wieder hier in Berlin und
deutschlandweit junge Menschen für ihre
Zukunft dafür dass wir ein lebenswerten
Planeten auch noch vorfinden wir
brauchen doch nicht nur eine
energiepolitische Perspektive für die
nächsten drei Wochen sondern auch eine
für die nächsten drei Jahrzehnte und das
bedeutet endlich alle Hürden alle Hürden
über Bord zu werfen die doch den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren blockieren zehnmal in
Bayern wir haben es in
Nordrhein-Westfalen geschafft mit ihnen
die Abkehr von 1.500 Metern 1000 Meter
abstandsregelungsvereinbaren vielleicht
braucht eine grüne Regierungsbeteiligung
in Bayern damit das auch in jetzt vielen
Dank
vielen Dank so felix banaschak war das
noch mal Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und den Reigen schließt jetzt in dieser
Debatte in der es um meinen Antrag in
der Unionsfraktion zur Energiepolitik
geht
Olaf in der Beeck klimapolitischer
Sprecher in seiner Fraktion ja Herr
Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
fassen wir mal zusammen ist ja irgendwie
völlig unstrittig wir leben in
schwierigen Zeiten der Angriff kriegt
Putins und der daraus folgende
Wirtschaft und ressourcenkrieg heißt
massive Auswirkungen in Europa und auch
in Deutschland damit habe ich schon
genauso viel mal Europa gesagt wie in
ihrem Antrag steht die Bundesregierung
und die Fraktion der Ampel arbeiten
jeden Tag mit Hochdruck daran die
Probleme zu lösen und die aktuellen
Herausforderungen zu meistern und genau
das was sie in ihrem Antrag fordern tun
wir Tag für Tag als Regierung und
Fraktion wir arbeiten
wir arbeiten daran Perspektiven zu geben
Preise unter Kontrolle zu bringen und
Insolvenzen zu verhindern aber eins das
wird uns nicht passieren wir werden
sicher nicht in Aktionismus verfallen
die Ampel arbeitet klar und strukturiert
lassen Sie mich
lassen Sie mich ein paar Sätze zu ihren
Ideen sagen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da unseren Fraktionen sie
wollen also die gasumlage abschaffen und
einen gaspreisdeckel sowie ein
bürgerbasispreis einfordern hört sich
alles toll an aber nur weil Kosten
gedeckelt werden die wohl Union musste
Differenz trotzdem irgendjemand Allrad
zahlen und glauben Sie dass das Geld vom
Himmel fällt ich bin gespannt auf Ihre
Vorschläge wie sie das mit der
Schuldenbremse in Einklang bringen ich
nehme es vorweg gar nicht vielleicht
sollte der Kollege Czaja einmal mit
seinem Bruder sprechen unserem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Abgeordnetenhaus
von Berlin der wird Ihnen das vielleicht
mal erklären wenn ich wie ihre Sammlung
wenn ich mir ihre Sammlung von Ideen
anschaue muss ich mich schon sehr
wundern was aus der Partei Ludwig
Erhards eigentlich geworden ist
fiskalpolitisch bewegen sie auf dem
Niveau der Linkspartei aber sei es drum
aber seis drum
vielen steht das Wasser bis zum Hals und
gerade im Hinblick auf die
Energiesicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
handeln wir eine entscheidender Schritt
ist zum Beispiel der Umgang mit der
deutschen rostlab Töchtern so
gewährleistet unter andern durch die
untertreuernstellung der
pck-raffenriemen in Schwedt die
Versorgungssicherheit in Ostdeutschland
als Liberaler ist es mir natürlich immer
lieber wenn der Markt wirken darf und
sie staatliche Eingriffe in Grenzen
halten aber in der jetzigen Situation
müssen wir pragmatisch handeln das ist
auch unser Verständnis von der Aufgabe
des Staates wenn der Gas- und Strommarkt
nicht mehr im Sinne der Verbraucher
funktioniert da muss der Staat in
Ausnahmefällen Eingreifen das tun wir
auch bei der Verstaatlichung
beispielsweise von uniper und ja der
Staat muss sich auch um den Mittelstand
und die vielen Betriebe in Deutschland
kümmern aber verunsichern sie doch nicht
die Menschen und erzählen Märchen dass
die Bundesregierung nicht zu unternehmen
würde wir wissen dass gerade die Preise
für Strom und Gas für viele
Schmerzgrenze liegen oder diese schon
deutlich überschritten haben deswegen
müssen wir nun alles dafür tun um die
Energiepreise schnellstmöglich zu senken
wir haben mit den drei
entlastungspaketen
entlastungspaketen bereits Maßnahmen
ergriffen und werden immer wieder
zielgerichtet nachsteuern ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das Ministerium in
Kürze Vorschläge für ein schnelle
Einführung der vereinbaren
strompreisbremse vorlegen wird die wir
hier in diesem Haus dann debattieren
werden und natürlich muss alles auf den
Strommarkt was wir zu bieten haben um
die Preise zu senken Kohle holen wir
schon zurück das tut mir als
klimapolitiker weh aber es ist notwendig
und können wir uns auch wirklich leisten
auch auf andere Energiequellen zu
verzichten wollen wir uns vorwerfen
lassen dass wir nicht alles dafür getan
haben den Menschen bei den absurd
steigenden Preisen zu helfen nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das können wir
nicht deshalb werden wir auch weiter
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidung in der
Ampel treffen das gilt im Übrigen
sicherlich auch für die letzte
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke das ist
unsere Verantwortung und daran dürfen
uns die Menschen auch messen dankeschön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Olaf in der Weg
aus der FDP-Fraktion war der letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte die in großen
Teilen eher polemisch geführt wurde
statt von neuen Argumenten geprägt
gewesen zu sein es ist vielleicht kein
Wunder der Bundestag hat in dieser Woche
rund viermal über dieses Thema
diskutiert da hätte man vielleicht doch
mal überlegen können ob man das
thematisch ein klein wenig bündelt also
wenig Neues in dieser Aussprache und
jetzt wird darüber beraten die mit
diesem Antrag der Unionsfraktion
umgegangen wird da steht zur Diskussion
ob er abgestimmt wird hier direkt oder
ob er
beispielsweise in den
Wirtschaftsausschuss überwiesen wird
dieses Verfahren wird jetzt hier gerade
besprochen und nicht das richtig sehe
haben sich Union und AFD dafür
ausgesprochen den Antrag zu überweisen
und genau das ist jetzt passiert
spannungspunkt 30 dann wird er an
anderer Stelle weiter diskutiert und wir
schauen auf den nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt an diesem Freitag an
diesem letzten Tag dieser Sitzungswoche
nächste Woche geht es ja übrigens direkt
weiter hier im Deutschen Bundestag es
geht um den Kinder- und jugendbericht
der Bundesregierung der ist schon im
November 2020 vorgelegt worden jetzt
wird der diskutiert Schwerpunkt ist in
diesem mal die für in diesem Jahr bzw in
diesem Bericht es ist der 16 insgesamt
die Förderung demokratischer Bildung
Grund für den Höhen höheren Bedarf so
sagen die Autoren der Studie sein die
Herausforderung durch Globalisierung und
Klimawandel sowie die Gefährdung der
Demokratie durch Populismus und
Extremismus mit den Kindern und
Jugendliche schon relativ früh
konfrontiert würden das also jetzt
gleich Thema in der sich anschließenden
Debatte wir sehen noch ein wenig in die
Rotation hier
bin im Bundestag die Fachpolitiker
wechseln naturgemäß bei den
verschiedenen Tagesordnungspunkten
Wolfgang Kubicki noch recht geduldig wir
sehen auch Lisa Paus die zuständige
Ministerin ist da steht auf und geht zum
Pult und dann geht es jetzt auch los
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen liebe
zuhörende der 16 Kinder und
jugendbericht zeigt die politische
Bildung junger Menschen ist ein
Stützpfeiler unserer Demokratie und sie
ist heute wichtiger denn je denn sieben
große Megatrends fordern die Demokratie
besonders heraus
Klimakrise und Pandemie Globalisierung
Digitalisierung demografischer Wandel
Migration Erstarken der Nationalismus
und natürlich aktuell sogar ein Krieg in
Europa
das alles beeinflusst auch das
Aufwachsen junger Menschen gerade in
diesen Zeiten kommt deshalb politischer
Bildung eine große Verantwortung zu
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
demokratie braucht DemokratInnen und
Demokraten und politische Bildung hat
den Auftrag junge Menschen zu Demokratie
zu befähigen Demokratie ist nichts was
man in der Schule lernt wie Vokabeln
oder vielleicht wie Binomische
Gleichungen sondern Demokratie lebt
davon dass wir sie jeden Tag miteinander
leben
und deshalb deshalb ist die wichtigste
Botschaft dieses Berichtes politische
Bildung gehört überall hin sie gehört in
die Familie in die Kita in die Schule in
die Ausbildung in Jugendbildungsstätten
oder in Jugendverbände alle Kinder und
Jugendliche haben einen Recht auf
politische Bildung meine Damen und
Herren
und politische Bildung dauert im Grunde
ein Leben lang in der Jugendarbeit beim
gesellschaftlichen Engagement in
Vereinen in der Bundeswehr in den Medien
und immer geht es um die klassischen
fragen wie funktioniert unsere
Gesellschaft wie kommen wir zu
gemeinsamen Entscheidungen und wie
verabreden wir Regeln an die sich auch
alle halten
das Ziel politischer Bildung ist aber
auch ganz konkret sich begegnen auf
Augenhöhe und mit Respekt zu lernen sich
eine eigene Meinung zu bilden aber eben
auch mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen
umzugehen und sie zu tolerieren und hier
wird auch außerhalb der Schule viel
geleistet das fördert mein
bundesjugendministerium sehr umfänglich
mit dem Kinder- und jugendplan und mit
Programmen wie Jugend der erinnert und
dem respekt-coaches und auch mit dem
großen wichtigen Programm Demokratie
leben
aber Demokratie Förderung ist eine
Daueraufgabe und deshalb werde ich
zusammen mit Nancy fazer das
demokratie-fördergesetz Einbringen meine
Damen und Herren
werte Abgeordnete Werte zuhörende ich
will auch dass 16-Jährige wählen können
in diesem Land
und ich will dass Kinderrechte im
Grundgesetz endlich verankert werden
der Bericht plädiert übrigens ebenfalls
für beides und die Bundesregierung hat
beides in Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
und ich persönlich werde da definitiv
nicht locker lassen
eine weitere Diagnose des Berichtes
lautes politische Bildung wirkt umso
nachhaltiger wenn sie mit handfestem
demokratischen Erfahrungen einhergeht
wenn eben Demokratie gelebt wird wer
früh mitentscheiden darf und erlebt dass
die eigene Meinung zählt dass man sich
auf demokratische Prozesse verlassen
kann der hat gute Chancen auch dann an
wirklich ein Demokratie Fan zu werden
und auch darum setzen wir den Nationalen
Aktionsplan für mehr Kinder und
Jugendbeteiligung auf meine Damen und
Herren
und wir stärken die politische Bildung
um Flagge zu zeigen um zu vermitteln
warum Gleichheit warum Pluralismus warum
Menschenrechte Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Gewaltenteilung und Minderheitenschutz
so wichtig sind denn es geht um nichts
anderes als um den unintergehbaren Kern
der Demokratie auch so nennt ihn der
Bericht
und weil der zwischen ganz viele
Zwischenrufe waren und bei ausgerechnet
die die es darauf anlegen die Demokratie
zu hintergehen behaupten politische
Bildung müsse neutral sein sage ich
ihnen eins politische Bildung ist
niemals neutral
politische Bildung ist demokratische
Bildung und deshalb wird sie eben
niemals neutral sein Gegenüber
Demokratie Feinden
politische Bildung ist auch deswegen so
wichtig weil sie macht junge und eben
übrigens auch alte Menschen resilient
dagegen
verschwörungserzählungen und rechten
Parolen auf dem Land zu gehen und
deswegen müssen wir Sie unterstützen ist
sie so wichtig ich danke der Kommission
für diesen wirklich wertvollen Bericht
meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin
[Applaus]
Frau Kollegin fester sie werden sich
jetzt mit einer Minute begnügen müssen
bedauerlicherweise aber so ist das
vorgesehen der nächste Redner ist der
Kollege Ralf Edelhäuser cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute über den 16 Kinder und
jugendbericht ein Bericht der zu einer
zeitverfasst worden ist und zwar im
September 2018 bis 2020 im Juli in dem
die corona-pandemie ja noch gar nicht in
vollem Umfang abschätzbar waren und
welche Folgen das sie hat und eigentlich
sind ja die entsprechenden
gravierendeneinschnitte für unsere
Jugendlichen und Kinder erst danach
entstanden wir alle wissen das was damit
zu tun hat es waren die
Schulschließungen es war der
wechselunterricht es war auch die
ungenügende Ausstattung von
Lernplattformen allen enthalten und
diese negativen Auswirkungen die hier
die jungen Menschen und die junge
Generation leiden musste hat natürlich
auch was zu tun dass sie mergelnde
Bereiche Kompetenz Entwicklung und
kognitive Erfahrungen gesammelt hat und
hier ist es an uns allen aber auch an
allen politischen Ebenen bis zur Kommune
runter dass wir das ausgleichen müssen
in den nächsten Jahren denn das
Vertrauen in die Politik hat letzten
Jahren gelitten auch das von
Politikerinnen und Politikern und
Jugendlichen die massive Einschnitte
erfahren mussten in ihre persönlichen
Freiheit zum Beispiel in den
Freizeitverhalten es war kein
Freizeitverhalten möglich was macht der
Jugendlicher jugendlicherweise treffen
wird zusammen sein mit Gleichaltrigen
Fehlanzeige das haben sie alles
ausgehalten aber doch wir haben
großartige Jugendliche weil sie wollen
demokratisch handeln sie wollen junge
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger in unserem
Land sein und dafür einmal herzliches
Dankeschön an die Jugend unseres Landes
nun gilt es aber auch den Jugendlichen
etwas zurückzugeben und da gibt diese 16
Kinder und jugendbericht auch
entsprechende Empfehlungen ab was genau
gemacht werden sollte damit unsere
Jugendlichen auch von unserer Demokratie
partizipieren und sich auch aktiv
einbringen können und wie wahrscheinlich
die meisten von ihnen für ich auch
regelmäßig Gespräche mit unseren jungen
und sie geben natürlich eindeutig zu
verstehen dass sie eine Zukunft ohne die
Jugendlichen nicht geben kann sie wollen
aktiv mitmachen sie wollen aktiv diese
Zukunft gestalten und eine Möglichkeit
dazu sind die Freiwilligendienste und
deswegen werbe hier auch an dieser
Stelle für das Freiwillige Soziale Jahr
oder buftis im sozialen Bereich im
ökologischen Bereich internationales ja
egal was hier heißt für die Jugend dass
es sich mit Arbeit und Leben
entsprechend koordinieren können da
lernen Sie was es heißt aktive
Mitsprache kritisches Denken auch
aktives gestalten und wir haben erst in
dieser Woche ein Fach gehabt da kommt
man das live erleben im
unterausschussbürgerschaftliches
Engagement und es grandios das ist super
und es ist wünschenswert wenn das
natürlich am Ende des Tages auch im
Bundeshaushalt des nächsten Jahres im
Bereich der Freiwilligendienste wieder
heil finden würde zum Beispiel in einer
Erhöhung der entsprechenden Stellen weil
hunderttausende Stellen gibt es und etwa
300.000 Nachfrage und jetzt stellen wir
uns einmal vor das Delta kann ja jeder
ausrechnen aber was das für eine Stadt
bedeutet Kassel hat 200.000 Einwohner
dieses Potenzial wird nicht genutzt und
das Potenzial müssen wir als Land doch
einfach nutzen das dürfen wir noch nicht
liegen lassen auf der Straße
denn diese Freiwilligendienstler sind
unsere Retter in der Not wenn es geht in
den Kitas in den Schulen in den Horten
in den Seniorenheimen oder in den
öffentlichen Bereichen hinein und
deswegen wie auch im Bericht angemerkt
ist es auch wichtig dass Menschen junge
Menschen die jetzt finanziell nicht so
gut ausgestattet sind da in der Familie
das auch die die Möglichkeit haben
solche Freiwilligendienste annehmen zu
können und hier müssen wir dringend
nachbessern hier müsste das ganze Breite
aufgestellt werden die aktuelle Zeit in
der die Jugendlichen heranwachsen ist es
schwierige Zeit wir wissen es alle
Corona ist noch nicht ganz vorbei die
Angst vor Armut die Inflation des
Kriegsgeschehen die Energiekrise das
sind auch Herausforderungen für die
jungen Menschen im psychischer und
physischer Hinsicht und deswegen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist in
unserer Verantwortung dass wir da ein
stabilen Rahmen geben der sie sich
entfalten können und auch politische
Verantwortung übernehmen können das
klingt wieder gut ist es auch
finanziellen Dank
Ralf Edelhäuser CSU Landesgruppe hat er
noch mal Glück gehabt und ist um eine
unmahnung rumgekommen aber sie haben
vielleicht im Hintergrund gehört dass
Wolfgang Kubicki der Bundestags
Vizepräsidentin gelegentlich auf sein
Mikrofon klopft wenn er wünscht dass die
Redner oder Rednerinnen ihren Beitrag
beenden jetzt ist der Pult Ulrike Bahr
SPD-Fraktion und Vorsitzende im
Familienausschuss des Bundestags
wirklich hört uns mal jemand zu diese
Rückmeldung bekam ich am vergangenen
Montag von einer Teilnehmerin des
Herings Heimerziehung Herr Kollege
Edelhäuser war auch dabei mit dem
hearing konnten wir im Familienausschuss
jungen Menschen die in Einrichtungen der
Jugendhilfe aufwachsen oder aufgewachsen
sind die Möglichkeit bieten sich direkt
an die Politik zu wenden
im Workshops hatten sie sich akribisch
und ausführlich darauf vorbereitet das
ist für mich geliebte Jugendpolitik den
politische Bildung darf nicht Theorie
bleiben sie braucht unbedingt auch
politische Beteiligung und
Selbstvertretung und Aufgabe der Politik
unsere Aufgabe ist es dafür die Räume zu
öffnen
der 16 Kinder- und jugendbericht stellt
diesen direkten Bezug zwischen
politische Bildung und Beteiligung sehr
klar und deutlich fest politische
Bildung vermittelt nicht nur wissen sie
soll Demokratie praktisch erfahrbar
machen damit ermöglicht sie dass ich
Jugendliche aktiv und gestaltend an
Politik beteiligen politische Bildung
befähigt Kinder und Jugendliche sich
entsprechend ihrer Interessen politisch
zu informieren und sich eine Meinung zu
bilden sie lädt ein zum einmischen und
mitmischen sie schult im kritischen
Umgang mit Medien das muss regelmäßig
geübt und angewendet werden und findet
natürlich nicht nur in der Schule statt
sondern immer in der Familie an
außenschulischen Orten und in
Jugendorganisationen
nach der letzten nach der letzten Reform